okay sometimes you gotta just you know
get started so let's do that this
episode is brought to you by gray block
pizza gray block pizza at 1811 Pico
Boulevard and that's a place you can
stop and get Italian if you're not
Italian you can at least fill your mouth
with it so get in there and get that
feeling in Los Angeles off Pico also
bronx-born pizza that's up in Bend
Oregon and that's a sister station to
gray block so if you're in one of those
two places get Italian fill your mouth
this episode is also brought to you by
Ridge wallet Ridge wallet it's a front
pocket carry a lot of times if you you
know you may sit on something and you're
like oh what did I sit on and it's your
wallet that's really crazy just be
sitting on your money because if you're
sitting on your money it's not at the
front it's nice you're not really
keeping it in front of you
you got your money on your butt and I
like to have my money out in front of me
so I can see what's going on with my
dealings and that's where Ridge Wallet
comes in handy Ridge wallet it's a front
pocket carry so you really minimize your
stuff you put it into a Ridge wallet put
it in that front pocket BAM where's your
money it's out in front of me where it
should be
Ridge wallet calm /co for a discount get
in there and get that here also I want
to let you guys know coming up I'll be
in Oxnard California July 6 through the
8th I'll be in Shanghai China
July 12th through the 14th also
Minneapolis Chicago Raleigh North
Carolina Nashville and Toronto are some
weeks coming up here in the soon time
you can get all those tickets and
everything do Vaughn comm slash tour t
oh you are today's guest I'm so happy to
have this beautiful funny hilarious
talented leader matriarch I don't really
know what makes it I don't really know
what matriarch means but it's very
important and this this lady is um she's
many things and she continues to evolve
but she's definitely
she's a seeker and she's a conqueror and
and we'll have her tour dates right
below but I'm so happy to have I'm so
happy to have this just this fire here
today miss Whitney Cummings
[Music]
Oh first of all I thought that they
honest I thought you were snow white and
on me that's when somebody take you know
says they took a couple of sleeping
pills and suddenly you know they don't
and then they don't come your graduation
wharves yeah these days a lot of these
words are out of control
yeah it could easily be nine I mean
here's the thing you see a couple of
dwarves over there [ __ ] easily five
or six more so uh really have you
started okay that's like my whole that's
my brand are we rolling
is this airing that's my whole thing
it's just hot it is good that doesn't
look good on you around whether machines
are I never know it does you wear that
pretty good well podcast you just like
there's no foreplay it's right here you
walk in the room and we're rolling so
it's like I just I want to be and you
know I took I took yeah you took to room
I took to time on p.m. by accident so
this is gonna get weird and is that a
new thing that like women are doing to
like challenge themselves more do you
feel like and I did it by accident it's
not a new thing that women or at least
this woman right mixes up labels okay a
lot cuz you seem like the kind of lady
is like you know what yeah what's lady I
mean I come on nine-year-old nice a lady
if she's that's like little lady right
little lady feels a little like old lady
okay you know you seem like the uh you
seem like the kind of a [ __ ] seems a
little bit like we kind of got off the
main dragon orient you seem like the
kind of Smitten Kitten that uh that's
like you know what
I'm such a bad [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
I'm gonna take half a thing I'm pin a
drill and go to this business like me on
a benadryl is about the level people can
handle right I'm too much when I'm not
on some kind of sleeping pills so maybe
this is good maybe it's good for my
brand do you think you're intense or do
you think of what is it that gives you
intensity is it like a confidence type
of thing I think it's the opposite I'm
pretty anxious socially which I think a
lot of people think that maybe I'm a
[ __ ] because I'm kind of quiet in
social situations and they think I'm
like judgy or something like I've had a
lot of comics actually like Sarah Tiana
like we didn't really talk for the first
couple years when I was at the Comedy
Store and she's like I thought you were
such a [ __ ] yeah no I was just like
scared and I'm kind of socially awkward
and
I just keep to myself and it like seems
like aloof and like I think I'm better
than people yeah and I'm really just
like cripplingly nervous in social
situation Wow yeah it's not really my
yeah cuz that's her I thought I was like
man this is she's so like she's a [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] getting [ __ ] done like
you always thought I was a [ __ ] really
I thought you were kind of [ __ ] yeah
really like [ __ ] like how I got a lies
a level but I thought that you were like
a couple back from there you know oh
okay
I like but you and I have known each
other for a very long time right but not
well though like we've never like been I
feel like we were cool like because we
used to do like bars together yeah like
Westwood bruco if you guys aren't in LA
it's a place on the UCLA campus that
they have a basically a room that looks
like Anne Frank's attic right next to a
karaoke bar you're screaming over like
wow thing it's awful yeah girls and then
people like yeah you can hear like the
Gestapo and they just you just feel like
crying like the college girls like
fighting with their boyfriends yeah but
I feel like a lot of Jewish girls crying
too because there's a lot of Jewish
girls in that area yeah so it's really
full circle there I feel like you and I
were at least like hang out and wait for
like six hours to go up that's true like
you know five minutes in front of for
drunk people and maybe I was intimidated
maybe I was just like kind of like I
think I'm more of like an intimidated
kind of time in my life probably just
like it was maybe afraid to talk to
girls as much as socialize or be on a
comfortable level so in my head I had
like this other idea and I was scared of
everybody too because I think I was
insecure about I mean this was it there
weren't that many female comics like
when I started like now there's like a
ton felt like I was like you bury so
bold to new die yeah Phyllis Diller know
that we're only yeah there weren't that
there weren't as many so I think I
thought in order to be respected by the
guys I had to like kind of be tougher or
something or like I never wanted to get
the reputation for flirting with comics
or dating Carla I think I would be like
a little more aloof
you know because at that time I was just
such a you know like did you feel like a
commodity there like in a way like and I
just mean it like this you feel like a
commodity like in the sense that okay
here's an attractive cuz we'll agree
that you're attractive we agree with
that
fact that it might have been an aid
point for this fee for the stress that
before the court is all gotten to I mean
he would have to come back in time and
ask people back then but I mean so yeah
a strong a funny confident attractive
lady I wasn't confident I think I came
off him office no but I definitely
wasn't confident me how can we not try
yet confident but like I feel like I was
confident but I didn't really it I was a
perception it was like armor you were
focused though I was definitely focused
cuz I want to be good and that was the
thing that I think was seemed
intimidating like I would see you like I
remember like talking like Jeff Ross and
stuff and I'm like aw man no no bad way
I was writing on the road
yeah so maybe and maybe people just
didn't know that I was writing on the
road so I kind of knew him a little
right but you know it's interesting like
yeah people thought I was like you know
super funny ones I was like she worked
so hard but it was back then like you
had to work twice as hard to get a spot
as a girl and like I felt all this
pressure that like because there were so
few female comics that like I have to be
funny cuz there's already this
reputation that women are funny right so
like I want to nail it for like all
women yeah you know like I had I put
Solman which is now ridiculous so Oksana
Baiul
no it's not about you'll have a branded
like no I think was she a gymnast is she
known for her she's a gymnast I think
she landed it don't people didn't think
she was gonna and she just stuck like
you know but I feel like FEMA ice
skaters that are in the Olympics are
known for being good at ice skater okay
I'm something of gymnast then with some
ice skating but off the ice what does
that call gymnastics gymnastics yeah
yeah and yeah who's somebody they just
landed one one time and they just like
that's what I'm picturing you just and
then like you know like because there
was when I started it was like when a
girl will go on stage that was like
everyone's cue to go to the bathroom
right I used to good they'd be like the
way that you got brought up by then back
then as a woman people be like so are
you ready for a lady are you ready for a
female comedian and everyone would just
you just feel like rustling and they
just get up and I would die like I just
hit like refund like I was just trying
you their money back so I felt so much
pressure to be good and
for me like you see I'm being too
intense I'm on Tylenol PM I'm being too
numb but I thought uh you know back then
like I also really want a comics to
respect me because I think there was
this sort of stigma that I carried that
because I had done like a couple like
vh1 shows and stuff where people thought
that I got too much too fast oh how I'd
remember any of that I really didn't
want comics to hate me or think I was
getting anything I didn't deserve
because like comedy clubs that's our
home like walking into a comedy club and
having people comics not like you that's
like your worst nightmare so I just
really wanted to like earn everything I
got because I do think there was also
you know there is pressure always on
comedy clubs be like we have to put a
woman on the lineup and they never
wanted people to think I was getting
anything I was getting because I was a
girl and I didn't want to get anything
just cuz I was a girl but at the same
time you want to get you see they had
this like low-key high key kind of chip
inside you that was like you know I'm
gonna be like a Amelia Earhart in a way
not dot but not disappeared like you
know no but she's a dude imagine this
okay first of all some women couldn't
even drive that well okay imagine
getting into a plane and if I can take
it off and say you're going around the
world oh I don't know what the bets were
in Vegas but every bet was on her not
[ __ ] coming back didn't come back
she didn't but still so brave to do like
a you low-key have like a little bit of
Amelia Earhart iki you said like you
wanted to kind of you know I mean you
had but you were you seem like you
always have had some laser focus because
I feel like you just came in like this
lightning bolt and then next thing you
know like you definitely seem like
you're always working hard thank you I
appreciate that
no doubt I grew up poor I know a lot of
like I didn't have any other option
right I didn't have a back-up plan and I
realized very early on that I have very
few skills I have a very specific set of
skills totally amazing and see that's
what town'll p.m. dumps I'm Liam Neeson
like I'm just messing up like words I
don't say a lot well no worries keep
doing this in a little bit we're gonna
do in aziz ansari act out in case like
we're at the same place and you get the
rest you know and she's smarter than
being 22 is like basically it's the time
of
age but no we oh we will do a thing in a
little bit where when this tunnel him
sets him or where how a man should
behave intoxicated wants to rest I
almost said incarcerated it's starting
to kick it it makes me again that one of
those right because the intoxicated role
play and the incarcerated role play a
very different role different orifices
yeah totally different totally different
posture different core engagement level
yeah no I didn't have any other options
and like I tried to do a couple other
things like I tried to bartend I tried
to be someone's assistant and I just
realized very quickly like I am just not
good at anything else so I was like I
don't succeed at this like I don't have
a back-up plan because you seem like an
astronaut much guys right really no I
just can't do that cuz yeah you just
seem like an astronaut and then you kind
of went you know no me I mean I was
doing the Comedy Store open mic for like
four years showing up at five o'clock
waiting for hours to eat [ __ ] for three
minutes I mean funny when people like
she like came out of nowhere I'm like
really I was doing rooster T feathers in
bowling alleys for five years I guess I
didn't know that I guess I didn't know
that really yes and this is my
procession my presentment it's just my
little perception you know but yeah to
me you just always seem like yeah just
like a like a like laser-focused you
know and but I always admired it I mean
I if anything else like though I'm gonna
you know I mean I feel like also but
it's a girl like going to comedy clubs
like I'm not gonna go [ __ ] a bunch of
dudes after you know okay so the how
about this new kiddie then you get out
what else made it out right right yeah
well that's the thing it always seemed
like you were there for the work that's
what it's my eyes because like there's
nothing for a female comedian in the
comedy club writer 10:30 when you're
done woman now it seems different cuz
now you it's like you have all these
like it feels like there's a lot of
girls who like I get texts a lot and
it's like can I open for you can I do
this and those kind of things are fun
and I want to have Malcolm X you mean
right but sometimes it's a bit more than
that you know which is like what do you
mean but are like here's what I'll say I
think can I open for you then open for
you like I feel like sometimes there's
that vibe there you know and sometimes
it's even a little bit more poignant
than that right but do you do you feel
like guys treated you different though
as you were never nice guys will always
be a little bit no matter
what if the girl walks up you know and
she's like dying of thirst in the desert
and she's like can I have some water and
you're like party's gonna be like can I
give it to you out of my day you know
like that's always gonna come as happy
but no but I mean not come but just if
you could get real water out of your day
okay but it's like men are always gonna
want or there's always a little bit of
that yeah yeah maybe I think if you were
the one of the few women around then it
would be wow I was really scared of
getting a reputation I would like hang
out with our open for Bobby Lee or
something on the rope he would sue
[ __ ] Bobby Lee and rice whoa like so
I think I just want to really distance
myself from any opportunity that people
could just assume I was sleeping with
comics I've never dated a comic write
ever you know and then I did the Rose
what about Delia though every day never
dated probably yes huh did he say no how
weird is it though that I feel like you
and Kristin starting to look like the
same person
oh sorry you have way nicer skin but
it's like you think I have a better
hairline and less facial anybody just
something's going on yeah and it could
be the lighting in here I do I do think
that um one time I'll p.m. and I'll
think I'm Chris D'Elia so I'm close as
well I get that a little bit I can see
that I think it's also the confidence
cuz it's like a narcissistic for me some
of us is the confidence to both you guys
think I'm confident that's so funny
Chris to me is the most confident human
being on plant I can't wrap my head
around that I'm in therapy at a 12-step
program to get his inner model and I'm
not even close I've got like two lines
but I don't yeah I yeah I'm really
insecure and maybe just when I'm quiet I
seem like I'm like have it together or
people are projecting right you always
think that people have it more together
than they really do right yes and I
pretend to have it together on Instagram
we all like project this life that we
don't even have yeah you know why am I
telling you this
well I don't know me what is talking
about it but I think yeah but uh do you
feel like were you always because IIIi
don't believe that you're not confident
that you know what I'm confident in what
I know I'm capable of but I don't con
fidence with like people and like
socializing like right I don't do small
talk I'm not good at it right and I like
to go straight to a big talk like I like
to go straight to like my meds aren't
mixing like are just sad
like just being like how are you how was
your weekend like I I just I'm not good
boring that's why you and daliyah vied
to delete doesn't [ __ ] swim in those
circles he's like oh y'all over here in
this ditch baby on the [ __ ] ocean
climbing out of that yeah I just am NOT
good with like just shooting the [ __ ]
yeah you know and I cuz I think I have
this this really and and my boyfriend
always makes fun of me about it cuz it's
like a it's a deficiency that I can't um
[ __ ] which is I think good probable
whoa I talked to right it can't be like
so it has oh that's great yeah I totally
yeah I know I hear that's like I just
can't [ __ ] people I think it's fair
to them it's a waste of everybody's time
so like my brain just shuts down and you
know what I think even in learning this
omona life recently that works so well
for this industry you know bullshitting
know it I feel like the few people that
do not and I can go right for their [ __ ]
that's where other people with this
money who are milling around on the
outside like where do I put my money on
what horse it's the one who's like oh
that's the [ __ ] horse that at least
knows exactly what they're doing or if
it I don't I'll be honest about it right
like you know I actually don't know what
the best color for the couches let's ask
someone who does know right like I think
it's really important to know your
limitations know what you can't do and
to tell people the truth because in this
business you're asking people to give
you a lot of [ __ ] money yeah and if
you're gonna go in there and like just
tell them everything's great everything
to trust you you know it's like here's
where I think the landmine is here's
what I don't think we're in a now here's
where I think we need help like I think
it just you know makes people trust you
because you're being trustworthy yeah
you know yeah so I just have a good I
have a hard time with that and I also
went through a lot of hard [ __ ] and it
was like hard for me to just sit around
people like what's up it's like oh my
dad died like it's just like the [ __ ]
that goes down in our lives it's kind of
gets harder and harder bull shows you
get older yeah you know but um but yeah
I mean I think I'm confident like I'm
working on new material now like I'm not
as confident now that I'm working on new
material when I have [ __ ] that's like
polish and I'd have this hour that's
like great I walk in the Comedy Store
and I'm like I've got swagger I'm like I
know this is gonna kill but right now
I'm like trepidatious and it's like
you're between Marc Maron and Sebastian
and you're just like oh god like you
know so I think a lot of times when I'm
at the Comedy Store now I'm just like do
I try that new joke or do I do I eat
[ __ ] with my new joke could I kill with
an old joke someone might have already
seen and then I got all in my head about
it
I think the more I do comedy the more
nervous I get
hmm it's weird oh that's interesting
kind of I don't think I was confident in
my 20s I think I was just unconscious
right and you're also more exterior
nning something then yeah so there's
nerves in that but there's also there's
trepidation because it's trial and error
totally whereas now it's a little more
like okay I know what I can do yeah but
now there's maybe a different type of
it's not like you're learning it it's
just now you're maybe I have some real
nerves because it's you know what you
can do and then this is just a new thing
landmine it's like now like stuff has
changed so much since we started like
there's more comics like you know I want
to see what other comics are doing to
make sure I'm not doing anything similar
because then there's gonna be a youtube
video that you've stolen something or
like you just got it like I think be
more on your game now like I don't wanna
get on stage and get sloppy and say
something by accident that's being
videotaped and gets taken out of contact
like this podcast like it's Autopia real
dumb it is weird
my career is gonna end today on my drive
back to the valley but yeah I think you
just have to be more on point now you
know comedy used to be a little more
casual for me but now it's just sort of
like oh if that's taken out of context
that I'm you know sexist if that's taken
out its race you know you just gotta
break awake you know what do you feel I
mean it's so funny like um you know they
had like when I hear stories of like I'm
sober like I'm almost two years sober
right awesome thanks appreciate it
it's interesting I mean I would do an
eight ball right now folks and if I must
say like and I think you know this but
you just like hmm it was like in the
last two years when you have that
clarity and all the energy you know it's
like it is just I think it's weird cuz
two years ago almost like to the day I
started hearing people be like yo have
you seen Theo's new set like have you
seen what's Theo's up to like I started
hearing about it right yeah you know
funny one of the things that made me
feel good was one time you said to me is
what does he mean long ago you're like
yeah everybody just keeps saying you're
so funny and for some reason I think
even hearing that come from like a woman
I think in a weird way
just made me feel like cuz dudes always
like her in that dang but you always
feel like because I think as it growing
up like like I
remember when I was in maybe 6th grade
like there was this girl that I was in
love with and I think in 6th grade
oh dude what how old are you in 6th
grade honey I love 13 yeah 12 13 that's
not love oh I was 80% hard dude look and
listen to this out of man's dick since I
was about four so imagine my dicks been
the same size is all story they told me
who's they they told me he was already
doctors everybody we get it you grew up
rich you had a medical insurance cool
every sports coach dude I'm were one
sports coach taking a picture of it your
dick who was not even a pedophile no
that's illegal but he wasn't a pedophile
I was just like I was like looking nice
tires on a truck it was like yeah okay
so okay so I'm obsessed with when you
realize you were molested like the day
you just we just caught it right here it
is hashtag time's up
I'm I'm here it's Theo has come forward
against this childhood basketball coach
who took a picture of his dick I know
the story you're telling yourself it's
like a tire on a car
you're molested it was it is this a bad
time I wasn't lost about Kodak did I'll
tell you this I bet it took him a couple
extra minutes to develop that shot
because I had somehow thrown some real
heat but I remember coach being like my
dick was so big it wasn't one our photos
coach Daniel I need you in here to see
this boy's dick that's illegal but not
as people a station or molestation
worries gonna be in it's a movie that
he's coming yeah her it's like I think
somebody touched me I think somebody
talked so we kept fondling my mom my
mole just happens to be on the tip of my
dick dude what a great YouTube [ __ ]
sequences is somebody that just sneaks
up on people and touches their [ __ ]
mole you on Megan's Law comp so a what
Angie's List which I mix up all the time
can we change the name of what get her
and here's the thing you go on [ __ ]
are you get into these up Megan's Law
sites next you know you're looking for a
carpenter next you know your [ __ ]
mode you know were you easily she would
build a children's nursery I'm just
saying
there's a lot of things going on out
there that people are not looking into
it sure it's true but I remember I saw
so going back to what we're talking
about I remember being like you know in
fifth grade or something and I was in
love with this girl right I love like
everything I knew like I mean I was just
sprouting aortas every [ __ ] day
thinking about this girl like and just
my ribcage is just full of just blood
for this woman artist they really are
like a spoken word poet I don't know you
are I mean I mean those people end up
[ __ ] usually selling sandwiches out
of a [ __ ] van no but you have very
out what's the word florid is that the
word florid look that up
it's it like you have very like flowery
delivery oh thank you yeah I remember I
the only way I could express this girl
that I liked or was having a red or
flushed complexion elaborately or
excessively intricate or complicated
well that makes it seem pejorative
having a red flows complexion I still
probably definitely have three
milligrams of cialis in my system from
probably a couple days ago because I'll
pop a 10 milligram just to [ __ ] hit
the streets just makes you feel a little
bit of fluff you know but I'd mix up say
Alice with they're all the same
are they yeah all the antidepressants oh
no no I mean this is an antidepressant
for sure erection really just out okay
okay okay gives you that fryer took you
know what I'm saying right that both
states don't call me brah sorry thank
you young lady
okay thank you not little lady a lot of
this is a layer I know someone this
sleepy I have a lot of rules but no this
is when women need to have the most
rules ladies about to pass out and I
just want you to know that I am strong
boundaries and I will sue you if you try
to penetrate any of my orifices oh this
is where I really this is you know that
what a Nantucket sleigh ride is it's
when you kill a whale and it's in it
retaliates that whales and mammals are
the strongest right when they're about
to die
oh what a final burst of energy and
that's me right now that's my Nantucket
sleigh ride and this is do not call me
lady and we want to make you as least
attracted to me as possible I think I've
always been the same amount attracted to
you kinda yeah but I'm gonna finish this
brief story real quick so I was in love
with this girl the only way I could
express it to her was in my prime
waise at this time I saved one day I
think it was Valentine's I saved all the
spit in my mouth one day during class
right and after class I ran up behind
her and just spit it all right into her
hair and that was like for me it was
like this is what did you think you were
gonna accomplish by that I just hope
this somehow through it maybe through
the genetics of it and all the just the
almost like an ocean like the ocean that
had been going on in my mouth the ocean
of the [ __ ] for high and low tide of
this saliva just the little the soap
more sober you get the more on drugs you
see him it's pretty great but I think I
just wanted but that's how like just
nervously said like a possessive because
spitting on someone is a very degrading
right thing it's going on out there fYI
streets sitting in the face happening
hashtag tinder and and I feel like it
was like you were trying to own her in a
way or just get your genetics onto her
low yak I think I just thought this is
the only way and I did hair you know I
just did hair I spit into her hair got
oh right yeah I'm not I mean this is
just when I look back on it now I'm like
this is the only way the woman you spit
on the front so you weren't that now all
this lick under their chin your clothes
is that a thing no okay yeah if a guy
did that to me during sex I would not be
able to stop laughing for like 45
minutes it's called the Virginia mud
trail have you heard about that it's uh
that's a great kid sleigh ride
intersects with something licking her
yeah that's when you eat grapes out from
under somebody's arm I think the yes and
that's a Marina del Rey wine-tasting
but no were we talking about before I
got in that while I was talking about
field well I have lots of questions
about the coaches that took pictures of
your deck oh yeah I'm filing a suit so
I'm just trying to collect data because
I am your defense attorney pretty
basketball son six and four one years go
Blazers baby Blazers for a good score
it's not that great it's not great when
your coaches are jerking off to your
girth of your day well they weren't yet
get off they were it was admiration it
was like you ever been to Rome where you
go look at the statues and stand
you walk away with your wife and go get
some pizza just like that you have to
pay like $300 it's not enjoyable at all
I went to Rome and to go see the Sistine
Chapel it was like eight hundred dollars
I was like [ __ ] art what do you can't
afford that
I know but yeah I mean even if you have
801 dollars you can technically afford
it right I mean I'm about to write that
check right
you know write a bunch of [ __ ] I've
already seen textbooks for 30 years yeah
now that Instagram like makes me I'm
like like saw this thing I really want
to go to Greece and I saw a bunch of
photos on Instagram I was like I got it
yeah I'm good I get it
you know I get it but you have you do
you seem like you get over things
quickly like you can kind of like move
to all the things quickly and someone is
right you know like like a lot of times
I'll plan vacations just as a form of
procrastination just to like get myself
the dopamine and the what you know to do
organizing something just because I want
to feel productive but I don't want to
actually do work and it's because I have
such bad perfectionism I get very you
know what is it perfectionism leads to
procrastination which leads to paralysis
work so what I'll do if I can't like
finish something or write a joke I'll
just start like planning trips and just
never follow through going I don't pay
for this trip but just putting it
together and stuff it yeah it's like
exciting yeah it's just a wait it's like
it's organizing things and planning
things reduces quarters also it's like
just a good way to kind of get right and
then you sort of like get out your
system it's like watching porn or
something yeah I look at houses and
vacation rental oh that's nice yeah I
got Airbnb and just like be like let's
see all these fancy houses and I'm like
I need to work harder and then I can go
what do you set your price range at on
Airbnb okay it depends if I'm actually
staying there I'll set it like two to
three hundred but if I'm just going to
like two to three hundred well if I have
my dogs with me if I have my that's what
I said it at you know like I I would
think you'd set it a liar it depends I'm
only stating an ever beaten me once I
did ayahuasca in Topanga so I rented
like a place out there it was expensive
yeah a lot of money did you feel did
that did you feel I get that experience
was pretty cool would you do it again
I'm glad I did it I think I will do it
again
he didn't give me a ton the first night
but I puked the entire first night and I
think commedia it's just a lot of prom
date set after prom like sorry that's
too easy too much I've you know what it
was it wasn't that easy but that's brave
that you did that that why did you do it
wasn't that easy to joke that you're a
sexual predator right in this getting
[Laughter]
your sick hiding in plain sight
I like the idea that you're just like
guys right now I'm obsessed with the
guys that have sexually harassed women
but they haven't been called out and
they might be a little annoyed because
it means that they're not famous enough
right there's something funny about
someone being like I mean no one's asked
me like what the [ __ ] I like you know
like just cuz you have to have a hot
career right now to kind of go down
that's true yeah maybe this is such a
blessing sort of just you're right
underneath you can still sexual harass
people and kind of like you're sort of
in the money zone right now
do you um but do you think she oh no
you're asking me about ayahuasca I would
do it again the first night it's
interesting because like first time I
did it I was like oh I feel like on some
level cuz comics what we do is we
overanalyze things or we see them from
like nine different places you know like
different facets or we like you know
have this oppositional thing where we
take the unpopular argument and prove it
like right we should you know and I felt
like I wast a little bit it was like oh
I feel like ayahuasca helps people who
aren't comedians just think like
comedians oh and then I felt like I just
thought like a normal person
it was weird it turned off a lot of
stuff yeah and there was a lot of stuff
that I just realized like masturbatory
thoughts and like the old tapes in our
heads and the old stories they just kind
of stopped playing because like a
spring-cleaning almost that's right yeah
exactly exactly just like it's just
deleting some of that static you know
and then I realized I was like and then
I was a chill and all I was doing I was
just like oh look at his shoes like look
at this wall and I feel like this is how
normal people think they just think
about like one thing at a time they
don't like overanalyze it or have to
make a joke about it was like four hours
where I wasn't thinking of jokes right
you know it's like clear and it's kind
of peaceful oh my yeah it was just kind
of like chill and then the second night
I puked a bunch but I had a couple
little breakthroughs that I feel like I
would have come to my own at some point
in my life but this kind of just
expedited it yeah you know yeah right
but yeah it's I get almost it yeah it's
like oh [ __ ]
this might have took me three years to
get through some of this stuff
especially the old tapes that you don't
see it's like it becomes their gremlin
that's kind of dancing over yeah that's
right and you're so used to it that
doesn't even occur to you yeah that you
need to clean it up and find your like
sit the [ __ ] down
yeah like I'm good your shirt on it stop
taking pictures of my dick and walk on
so it was like six and four baby I baby
Blazers no that was our schedule in six
is the wing you only do the winds first
okay got a six and four got a gotta go
yeah six and four baby Blazers dude and
one of our players had to quit at twelve
because he got a woman pregnant dude at
12 yeah and it was a black guy a woman
iron girl was he got a girl how was we
they were in love I guess they were
children you know she was probably 16
cuz he wasn't trying to get her pregnant
by spitting on the back of her back he
did it the right way he knew how to I
got a bomb glad the bird the birds and
the bees talk and I got came from a
hairdresser because I could not have
just been dead for that you know what I
did yeah I'm trying to think of what I
would do if I guys spit on the back of
my head but what if years later you
found out that the thing was that the
guy just was so in love you just thing
it's like I loved you it's like no
bleeding just not true I'm in this
dumpster
what are you talking about in your
girlfriend's pregnant like you don't
love me like that's just not even true
that's like that rapper ex tenacious you
see this guy that diabetes of he be like
abused his pregnant girlfriend it's like
a shot I think he got shot probably by
the baby hopefully stuck an arm out with
a gun in it yeah it's a lot to process
but yeah that was it so like I don't
know how we got in this in the beginning
ayahuasca I was talking about Airbnb
where how did we got here before that we
got into something Nick do you know we
on top ok thanks Nick there's no name
just keeps looking at me with a very
perplex like kind of shocked but also
concerned look I just got a lot going on
I've been dating you ever met anyone
you've date I've never seen you like
dating anyone I don't think yeah that's
what thing I do I don't bring any of
that like around I think that when
you're mysterious
she like in comedy clubs people project
on to you what makes them feel more
secure right so it's like I haven't seen
it with the girls I'm like oh Theo must
be like a player he must be aloof or
much you know what I mean it's yeah
people think he might be gay might be
this he might be aloof yeah anyway I'm
not if you think you are I'm gonna
disagree I'm gonna fight you on that no
try to come out right now I will no I'm
not coming out right now dude especially
on next is beautiful gaming you're gay
no I don't think so I mean dudes try to
a lot at night you know what they'll be
like oh you might be gay you know sex
with you I think to try and make moves
like I mean I think there's like a gay
gay guys are always trying to get the
straight guy really I think so you're
saying you know yeah it's like yeah
that's a compliment probably it's a
little unflattering sometimes when guys
are like like you like I'll get a lot of
dick pics in my damsel [ __ ] it's like
this is [ __ ] gross dude yeah like can
I call those guys out can I call this
cuz it's kind of [ __ ] up by name maybe
don't do my name but I mean or like
what's so upsetting about it just that
it's gross why you think dicks are gross
no I love this this no I don't think
they're gross like if you're [ __ ]
coach and assistant coach mr. Danny
admire them and [ __ ] think your baby
plays this look by the way that's also
what they called your deck FYI
dude I earlier people would cheer for my
dick from the stands like she wouldn't
well it looked like a couple ladies were
looking one time that's not I know
because they were point oh remember
anything at this stage in your life I
perfusing I remember my Amistad I
remember carrying around a heavy dick
for [ __ ] eleven years dude I remember
my [ __ ] Amistad dude because I
imagine have an adult's dick now imagine
having tits at [ __ ] five um bin bags
imagine I'm in this big beautiful
feminine I don't like that term I don't
like it either and Nick I it doesn't
imply what the bag is full um when I
think of a bag I think of a bag of [ __ ]
on a door that discussed higher the the
title of p.m. just kicked in did you
hear I don't think we're deep you know
but like a bag I think of like like
alcohol in a bag or like [ __ ] on someone
there's big beautiful life alert
bracelets how about that that kind of
thing what shape is my okay wouldn't
those be like little triangles or like
little sad that's true Maggie I'm gonna
quit I'm stuck I don't want bags bags
and a lot of web bags what I like is
these uh hemispheres okay
these hemispheres to the to the original
realm okay perfect kind of perfect
because you yeah it's like right before
you leave your mother you need that last
sip off your mom you know and so that
but anyway imagine being five and having
breast suddenly or at the playground
near the girl with big you know so
you're saying your dick was so big when
he was a same dick the same dick you
grew an adult dick as a kid yeah yeah
and I remember what if you just have I'm
still taking a kid body magic confuses
me do you remember the show Everybody
Hates Chris that Chris Rock show were
like yeah Canada I knew someone that
wrote on that show like this is how like
I'm like real ditzy about like like some
things like people tend to think people
are always really surprised at how dumb
like I can't open like a door the key
like I can't figure out the weight like
I'm really did see about some [ __ ] and
when I was talking to this guy that
wrote on Everybody Hates Chris knee so
gonna have to stop the show cuz the kid
is growing up and I was like no you
don't just make everything around him
huge right they just give like a big mug
and like I thought I'd like save the
show I thought I like cracked it I was
like BAM get your set designers make
everything giant like make the couches
so he looks like a kid and they were
like you're a [ __ ] idiot like I can
be real dumb about Chile like that's a
two billion dollar my venom oh now what
I just [ __ ] nailed it saved yeah
everyone still got a job six and four
because the inner monologue would change
right what of Chris of the kid well no I
just visually thought he could still
look like a kid like if you put him in a
big chair he's it's gonna look like a
kid all right give him a big ass like
like coca-cola family so like trying to
figure out the size of your dick to your
body I'm not the person asking about
this I have a blind spot
oh I remember people I mean it was just
crazy
it was you Beyonce Alice do you talk
about this stuff on here I think you
kind of yeah I mean I take it like
sometimes I'll take it if I need to feel
a little bit of a little cuz you didn't
know I don't get too good erections in
LA man what does that mean what just in
there so the city's so intense it's just
like there's always this [ __ ] buzzing
that makes me feel so nervous canceling
headphones yeah but I need it's just
like it goes into my core here dude
second my plane lands in another place
man no but that's the thing I from what
I understand guys get erections when
they land in new cities it's like a
primal thing like I'm in a new place I
need to impregnate and airplanes
airplanes you have every dude in red hi
ladies if you wanna [ __ ] a guy and you
just met him you know no one wants that
you don't need to give this advice no
one wants this advice if you if you want
to [ __ ] a stranger I am great if I don't
wants that and if they if that's what
they want they're not listening to your
podcast they're in an alley so just we
could move on to the next topic
okay now erections Corrections are
basically their original original viagra
but they know they can only accompany
840 people at a time and it costs 360
dollars to get it up
it was erection an airplane I mean an
airplane will give any man an erection
really there's something about it there
is nothing less arousing to me than
being on a tube full of farts for four
hours how is that arousing to anybody
the idea of having and after get on a
plane the idea of anyone procreating
with anyone because you realize our
population crisis is out of [ __ ]
control when you gonna play no I'm not
[ __ ] anyone ever I'm tying my tube
yeah as a society we [ __ ] way too much
that's my takeaway from plans really yes
mine is I just get you I get so erected
and I'm and I dude one lady woke me up
and called me out had an erection told
the flight attendant that you hadn't
right well you know the actual assault
on planes is going up I just read I was
asleep and the erection wasn't for her
you know this lady coming up her
husband's sitting there like a straight
muffin I'm like this ain't for you lady
like I was dead asleep
you're saying that my natural biological
process and then what happened here the
attendant come over yeah and the
attendants trying to like you know stay
out of a lawsuit like try not to say
anything the lady's husband I'm looking
at the dude like really like this
[ __ ] meatball wife of yours is this a
common thing that guys get erections on
airplanes I don't think I've ever had
that happen Dixon here Nick do you mean
boner yeah I don't get a lot of land
dick these days dude what's land dick
like when you get erect on the land you
know so I'm I'm more airtime erection so
sometimes I pop that sigh ah let's do
just to feel a little bit uh hello that
last oh it can last three or four days
kind of an a mild tone an erection no
not the erection just that just that
little first but what does it do
serotonin it increases the serotonin in
your brain is that what Silas does do
you know what it's doing to you
neurologically no okay maybe you should
find that out
yeah can we look at what Silas does
because if it's for directions I think I
know what it does you want to know
what's going on your brain you know it
makes you feel erect but I mean it makes
you erect sometimes but it also just
makes you feel like um you ever heard
that song we got the beat we got the
think I'm a [ __ ] like Amish I don't
know it's a Russian hit no it's not it
sounds like this you have to be we got
do you pay for that everything like that
oh my god but I it makes you feel like
that's kind of playing in the background
of your dick like you got the
opportunity to have an erection so when
you hear noise like distractions in LA
you have you can't get as good an
erection if you're distracted I just
can't feel comfortable in Los Angeles
that's my problem yeah I got that when I
get somewhere else
I live in Westwood right yeah yeah but
it's just like is it the well you know
the fact that we are always on pavement
that reduces our ability to align with
the electricity from the earth you had a
jerk yes our grounding so go stand
barefoot on dirt every day for 30
minutes see if your dick gets any better
and it might cuz that's most of my
childhood now is fully to say I think
we're not barefoot enough cuz we have
pavement and the soles of our shoes yeah
but you and so something about the
electrons in our body I'm gonna get this
wrong please google it cuz I'm gonna
[ __ ] it up
but um it so if you're sick or anything
and apparently that is connected to a
lot of why there's so many illnesses
mm-hmm because we're never barefoot I
could see that easily that's why people
on the beach always seem healthy and
they're yeah yeah yeah yeah I have this
so what about the grounding I think yeah
I need you earthing in ground yeah I
think what about is funny I just got
insecure on this yeah
no our podcast is even a funny podcast
okay got it yeah thank God it really
isn't because here's what happened it's
like comics like you work so hard to be
funny now everyone has a podcast and
it's like now just don't be funny during
the day right for two hours like I just
figured out how to be funny and now I
can't you know I just bomb for two hours
no I don't think I don't feel like in
here we taught it before do you feel
like it Nick it's not really funny in
here sometimes really it just comes
naturally out of the time real deep
conference I never know what I'm
supposed to be doing in podcast so just
I truly don't know well I guess I mean
the other some things I was thinking
about like for one I was thinking about
what about this so say if a man takes
some cialis or levitra or some and I
don't love each or my teacher Dale I
think it makes your shoulders less
slopey and someone already done a joke
that that's the name of a but so say
this a man takes that he goes on a date
okay no and say he and the woman have
been talked texting about sex and stuff
like that and I'm thinking about doing
say okay doing this act now the date
ends right they go their separate ways
maybe you know they split a bad [ __ ]
dessert and you know what I'm saying
hurt you know why do I feel like this
isn't Maggiano's where were you
picturing Kristalina that he looks like
every angry waiter and a macaroni grill
and I can die laughing even though he'd
never been a macaroni girl
and that's the power Chris D'Elia he
just knows when something is [ __ ]
yeah we just get why because he is the
more specific the funnier yeah it's so
[ __ ] specific but I remem
and yes say the day goes awry right like
he has a something happens and you off
now you you're on cialis okay you're out
and about yeah you were gonna feel more
motivated for sex if something then
happens say that someone does ADD and
they sexually assault a woman or these
drug companies liable oh no uh no
because that's like saying guys that
drink whiskey and rape someone it's the
whiskey's fault
no it's a human's fault you still make
choices right you're still making a
conscious choice with your prefrontal
cortex that doesn't shut down your
prefrontal cortex right you're still
making that decision right like
Roseanne's tweet was not a man's fault
right like I've taken ambien [ __ ]
every day
for my entire life I mean I've done two
Tylenol PM stick it right yeah like
please
although by the way if I suck in this it
is the time p.m. fall it should be very
fair we're gonna put a disclaimer the
whole time but everybody else not the
case yeah it's like you can't blame
alcohol it's like if you if you know
people don't get off on a DUI just right
you know you don't sue Zima for a DUI
right so but like I love the fact that
you you just blew past Emma you're just
like Zima like oh dude Zima I think I
should make a comeback to you I'm
assesses even though it was so easy now
that's another thing get an erection on
Zima
you know that was Zima I feel like the
same is the opposite oh if I were to
zoom a twist off in the distance my
[ __ ] neck got longer just heard that
think it's like a Pavlovian response
I can leave up that Mike's Hard Lemonade
heart and Mike's hard okay sorry guys I
have to keep drinking coffee so that
this town doesn't win this [ __ ] is
owning my neurology right now somebody's
gonna find her in one of the hallways
right damnit like I am so stoned out of
my mind that I think TJ has our TJ I'm
calling you TJ well it's because we're
just talking about rape culture and
stuff what's he Jim no that's not what
that's not what happened do you think
that's what happened in my brain it
could have been no we're we're talking
about rape culture kind of no I feel
like sometimes I think of a woman's
around in LA you're always talking about
it that you're I feel like it a little
bit especially like I feel like feet a
lot of to me it seems like a lot of
women feel like especially celebrity
women like they have to be on some of
these boats or they're gonna lose their
audience you know there's a fear of that
you know your honor if you seem like it
as much because you also seem to do like
you seem to do like your own thing and
this is obviously my perception of what
the [ __ ] do I know you know okay gimme
but yeah you seem to do your own thing a
little bit more but I feel like there's
like a lot of things a lot of times that
women feel like they have to jump on the
bandwagon to continue to be relevant you
know maybe this is an LA thing in
general I don't know I mean I just think
in general like
right now I think a lot of people are so
desperate to speak and so desperate to
be heard and we're comics we have an
outlet we get to go up every night and
like be seen and heard and I think a lot
of people that don't like social media
is all they really have
it's like I don't feel the need to like
populate my social media with all my
political beliefs because I get to go
onstage and do it or like make a special
or something right you know I get to put
it in TV shows like there's ways I can
get it out right you know right yeah
it's a good point I've never thought
about that is like oh you get to be a
voice for you know for sometimes for
people who don't really have one maybe I
you feel like that sometime I definitely
used to feel a lot more pressure to like
be a role model or something but that's
me taking myself too seriously that's
just like such a narcissistic thought
you know if we're what created that do
you think you've had that before you got
in the industry you that when they were
less female comics I think I put
pressure on myself you know to be like
all right like you know don't look too
sexy but also still be feminine so women
feel like they can have permission to be
permission to be feminine but don't
become like a guys comic and like come
off really strong and don't admit too
many insecurities so that girls don't
think you're insecure and then I was
like but being vulnerable enough to
where they feel like they can be
vulnerable and so powerful like I just
was like so in my head about all that
[ __ ] and that was like you know what
you're never gonna please anybody but
like there's I mean we're just at a time
where it's just like you know it's such
a [ __ ] mob mentality and everyone's
got a comment everyone's got a problem
like I mean I posted something my dad
died last year
and how dare he I know something selfish
which by the way I just got an email
from him you know mailer daemon is that
what it's called we know you got a
really bad Mouse back like two months
ago and I was like my dad is still
rejecting me from the grave like this is
like but anyway so I did this little
suit first of all I mean Herbert I know
right
and then it's Father's Day so on
Mother's Day and Father's Day I posted
something that was kind of serious
that's just like because it can be hard
for people that don't have fathers or
mothers who are like women who can't
have kids Mother's days a little bit
like social media now you're just like
constantly being bombarded by things
that can make you feel bad about
yourself or compare yourself to other
people and like so I did this thing that
was just like happy Father's Day with
all the people that don't have fathers
or who don't have good relationships
with their fathers that can be tricky
and like whatever and like a lot of
people were really appreciative but then
there's people like you're good [ __ ] you
my dad is this the post to yell at me of
is this so I literally am like my dad's
dad
I just want to send love to all of you
who have a dad dad [ __ ] don't you're
old like doesn't what why did you get a
facelift I'm like Jesus like I'm just
over here crying like just wait till
Monday
yeah can you wait seven hours to insult
my looks
do you mind can I just grieve my
father's death but for a tout like crazy
so yeah everyone's gonna you can't
please everybody anyway so but some of
this has to come to a head where we quit
trying to like anybody oh please kind of
a little bit really I think it's just a
cialis no Connie is that the two
milligrams but God both to both of this
is my shirt my like you do have a shirt
like I'm on an airplane you feel trapped
know how does feel erect sure a meeting
shirt like this is my podcast shirt it's
like this is my go-to shirt it's like
not trying too hard but still kind of
trying yeah but I sweat through it I
like it well I think a lot of seeing
women sweat I think is a little bit sexy
and really yeah I don't like women's
deodorant like after a while I think of
people smell kind of I did like I only
were I do deroun is carcinogenic but I
was a Lube in a minute and the link
between breast cancer so I try to just
do natural deodorant but when I'm in a
new relationship I'll go back to the
secret you know I mean my dirty little
secret and one time I was with my
boyfriend and I had put deodorant on and
he I guess licked or his mouth something
and then I kind of open my eyes and I
just saw him go yeah it's like you know
when you a deodorant your mouth like
there's it's such an unmistakable
consider definitely do that like part of
your tongue it goes numb oh that's
called a uh-oh dude that's called the I
think it's called a Hartford back alley
yeah
that's not a Connecticut that's that
Hartford back alley we actually look at
girls you know I think it's real dry
because it's a hit anniversary so it
takes all the [ __ ] water out here
talk that like sandpaper on the truck
and I saw him because I remember he did
it and I'd like squinted just to look
over to God
buddy used to do that when his
grandmother of ET laude put a little bit
of deodorant on her tongue no yeah he
did have her quiet down a little bit and
she didn't mind you don't think is a
little bit of attention but um one thing
I want to say is this so oh so when when
the Rosie anthing quit you quit the show
before that though I quit the show much
before yeah cuz I remember seeing you at
the improv and you were like it's it
felt like something was weird was
something weird over there you didn't
like it
well I only planned on doing one season
of Roseanne I always plan on doing one
season did you watch the show growing up
oh yeah I loved it growing up it was
such a big deal for me like I grew up
poor and I was watching 9:02 and oh and
Melrose Place it was feeling rescue Nam
oh boy I know I would watch a Current
Affair that was my [ __ ] but know what's
rescue night when one is just like was
William Shatner dude oh yeah his people
always called 9-1-1 and the police in
our neighborhood so be like oh yeah that
was the show we're like you would see a
neighborhood and then you see him like
walk into frame yeah you know I mean he
just like hey everybody and no so I love
the show growing up and when they were
talking about it coming back it was like
right after Trump had become president
right super everyone I think was super
like overwhelmed by that and then right
you know I was trying to figure out a
way to help I think as a woman him being
the president is very challenging right
sure it's triggering and hard and
stressful and I think I just want to
kind of figure out why cuz everyone's
like trumpeters are stupid they're
sitting like yeah I hate that guy I
don't like this it's not helpful it's
not helpful it just makes it more
Redskins versus Cowboys it's not a
mature argument it's not sophisticated
it's also not true yeah and then I found
out a lot of white women voted for Trump
and I was confounded by that and I
usually like to do projects that have a
question that I don't know the answer to
I'm gonna be able to learn something
like this I motivate you know it's just
sort of like and then I was like what a
great way to like use like contribute I
know I knew people that were like you
know trying to raise money for Planned
Parenthood and make cupcakes I can't do
that type of [ __ ] yeah my jam and I was
like maybe this could be a great way to
start a conversation help with this
national healing process because there's
gonna be people with different points of
view I had these like really like noble
intentions which you know ended up being
a fool's errand and Wanda Sykes was
working on an enormous Donald and you
know Morgan Murphy and like all these
great people in the room
so and Rosie it was always so
progressive back in the day remember
there was that the Jackie domestic
violence episode when fish or hitter
oh yeah the black girl in the school
play DJ wouldn't kiss the black girl in
the school play and she admonished him
for that with this like triumphant
monologue about how black people are
just as good as we are and like it was
always said she was so pro woman so Pro
gay like so I was really interested the
fact that she just voted for Trump 20
years later and a lot of family members
that voted for Trump or support him they
were always so cool before so I'm just
kind of but I have like it when you say
that I have like I have tons of friends
who are all the things you say like Pro
black / Pro gay all those things but
also voted for Trump well Roseanne's
point not that I think we should really
take any of her points to be valid given
what we've seen but like the reason I
think I was comfortable working on X I
sat down with her nose like I didn't
know why you voted for Trump and not
that this is necessarily true it seems
like you know she's kind of off the grid
at this point mentally but like she said
she was like well I was a Bernie
supporter yeah that's what I was - she
was Bernie or bust yeah so I was like
that's interesting so you're crazy
liberal but then you vote for Trump like
that's so I wasn't she was like Trump
from the beginning no it's like I wish
Bernie and Trump would've ran on the
same ticket honestly interesting and
then well that's like [ __ ] mine melons
but it would have been it would have
been - it would have been too and I
think a lot of people felt that way okay
and that's the thing I think that's what
the day's nothing they could never write
but that's where you're gonna get a real
to real people having to see other
people sighs anything like that or go
for vice president well he has no power
Trump for vice president and then Bernie
for president I don't think Trump would
ever be vice anything right he's an
egomaniac right but there I mean I think
they're all ego maniacs but but so what
did she say so then she said and I was
like but he's racist and like sexist and
all these things and she was like
totally I the things he says are crazy
right but jobs is really what fixes
racism and sexism give them money
write them elevate now right all right
you're wrong and he's gonna I mean
there's some truth to that but it's like
he's not gonna fall through the any of
these promises but I get I guess your
motive is make sense she's like always
been so honest she's oh she's only doing
so lovely she was actually really lovely
during production she was so sure she
was so grateful to be there all of the
best I also didn't follow her on Twitter
which is makes me if I can
I hadn't seen like the past tweets that
were sketchy but she would like take him
down and then she put him up and take
him down so it was like okay this is all
about the greater good and this shows
gonna be so healing and then it came out
and when Trump called her and we made a
very balanced show that is not pro Trump
at all it really kind of like um
explored the circumstances that led to
him being president right never named
him
we actually like made fun of him quite a
bit it was not approached I'm sure soon
when he called her and was like taking
credit for it was like dude you didn't
see it homie like you know and so um but
then I was like you know I'm good this
is you know I don't really want to run
other people's shows I just want to kind
of be a part of this and then it was a
stressful there um it was stressful
because I think in the it was very hard
for me to write like for someone I
didn't disagree with but there are so
many other characters on the show so
when it came to Roseanne I was having a
hard time separating Roseanne Connor and
Roseanne Barr that was my biggest
struggle and Roseanne Connor 20 years
ago in a Roseanne Connor now right
so it's kind of like okay so for as AM
believes this that doesn't mean Roseanne
Connor believes this and she would kiss
Roseanne's rich and she lives in Hawaii
right you know I mean so but Roseanne
Connor has $400 and listen Lanford so
you know that was the hardest part about
it and there was a ton of pressure I
think on it because it was so highly
anticipated right and John Goodman and
Laurie Metcalf er you know you just
wanna [ __ ] nail it yeah there was a
lot of fighting in the room which is
good that's what writers room is yeah
felt kind of this year a lot of stuff
fell for us like I just watched the
first few episodes a lot of felt stuff
felt like a little bit force to me you
know but I mean I guess but I mean first
episode back after 20 years we had to
force a ton of time to get it going yeah
yeah that's what it that's what TV is
forcing people to show up and say the
things you wrote for that did you I mean
I don't know when they enter music
started I was just like yeah it took me
like it was almost like Narnia it was
like walking through the back of the
closet and like so nostalgic did you
feel how did you feel once the show when
it was when it went away were you
surprised no I mean it's interesting
because I think for me like the goal of
all of us working there was to do this
thing where we were gonna I mean granted
maybe like we're narcissist for thinking
that we could have an impact like this
but it's like we wanted to contribute to
like the country healing and like it
like but half the country isn't
hurt but here's what I'll say it's like
liberals and conservatives however you
define it at whatever like the one thing
they could agree on is we like the show
Roseanne right you don't I mean I like
when I would go around the Russian and
be like Roseanne people will go crazy in
the audience like I that is the one
thing I feel that and like porn right
the one day Warren first - so the people
watching Fox News are John Oliver News
or Samantha bee if you put Lampron
Illinois in a woman's butthole out there
you could just you could blow the whole
internet off place so I can say that it
is based on Elgin Illinois I think is it
really Elgin watches were made yeah but
the company is closed I know a lot of it
I haven't been there I love Illinois
then I'll be in Stark County Illinois on
June 29th for a fundraiser yeah and I'll
be in Chicago outside of Chicago
Illinois in August will you I will up
that plug oh you're you're at all the
Improv I'm doing yes that one outside of
yeah it's big yeah Schaumburg because
I'm working on my new special and I need
to go do an hour like places that's
awesome yeah and we'll put your dates -
at the front - yes definitely like I
don't know I think we all wanted this to
be a part of like the healing process or
some kind of like cool statement or
something and then I think that maybe
you know although it's not the package I
was hoping it would come in the wind was
that Channing Dungy at ABC this awesome
black woman cancel the racist white
woman that's what needed to happen you
know right so it's not how I thought it
was gonna go down but maybe that's
ultimately the best outcome
yeah do you feel like Roseanne's a
racist I mean yes we Twitter is
dangerous
Twitter should like Twitter's dangers
for senior citizens and first of all I
don't even know anybody who's [ __ ] on
Twitter anymore like Twitter is ass
[ __ ]
anybody who comments or replies on
Twitter it takes people it's all [ __ ]
losers that said I'm gonna do nothing
that's what I find and here's what I'll
say like like I'm it's so weird when you
just said that cuz there was a moment I
was like okay because I cannot wrap my
head around the fact that Rosanna's
racist like it's still so crazy to me
cuz growing up with her the two best
friends on the show Chuck and Emery
we're black that's what they are black
they haven't changed right so issue
races or she just say a tweet that
somebody who's 65 years old on Twitter
might say I don't know I don't think we
can like qualify and defend because we
will never know the answer the reality
is like you have to take responsibility
for have you send the racist
you're racist like we don't I mean it
gets it's kind of that's if you rape a
girl you're a rapist like if you rape a
girl you're a rapist if you say
something on Twitter or you or dad there
were other things right yeah I think if
yeah if you look at her old saying she
cheats she looks for some type of type
of controversy look I think that if that
was the first tweet she had ever sent
right we might be like oh maybe she's
never used Twitter maybe she like like
but that is it's so irresponsible it's
actually what she did was like like
slightly above the n-word and actually
like it was just sort of like you know
because I I mean it's just I'm still
shocked as you can tell about it even on
Tylenol PM I'm like getting analyzed and
freaked out but it was like there when
we went back and looked there was like
years of oh yeah if you going on here I
say thinking it that's your business
I don't necessarily agree with you but
deciding to put it out there what a
different level and you voted for Trump
like it's just there's so much other
like ancillary evidence that may if she
had voted for Hillary and had never
tweeted it we might all go like maybe
this is amiss maybe we should figure out
what happened here and she's Roseanne
and she was always so progressive but it
was just like it was there was just too
much there was too big of a case against
her for me to like be like no she made a
mistake
right Janet [ __ ] you right 200 people
are out of a job right do you feel like
a B's but ABC also it's like should they
it was it ABC ABC should they have been
letting like the shouldn't have in
something in the contract
Rosen's not allowed to tweet yeah like
she had 200 followers at the time it kid
no one right thinking about why she
wasn't started up in the middle of the
night yeah totally like it was like as
the show like no one what no one was
prepared for this and no one ever
thought this would happen cuz who would
be so crazy to do that in Roseanne is
smart yeah she is smart oh I'm sure that
I mean she navigated an industry at a
time when it was well I think that if
I'm gonna be honest and like that is
what a lot of you know the people on the
show we're concerned because she was so
silenced for so long and she had created
this show and she wanted to do certain
things and they were like easy honey
like will write the scraps and she was
minimized and
was denied creatively and she had to
fight tooth and nail for so long that by
the time you know it's time for to
comeback and like people have decided
women are funny and concerning TV shows
and have creative autonomy I think like
a lot of the producers were like we
don't want her to feel like she's being
silenced again you know because that
didn't go so well the first time so I
think it was like you know everybody's
way of making her feel like she's being
seen and heard and not having her First
Amendment rights taken away or being
silenced creatively or whatever but I
had to talk with her because some of the
tweets were she was like retweeting like
fake news stuff and I had to talk with
her in the beginning and I was like
what's up what's going on why were you
in Twitter what are you doing and she
was like oh no I retweet that because I
think it's crazy I'm like well if you're
gonna retweet something that you think's
crazy you have to say something I think
you're endorsing edge right oh so in my
head I I kind of thought she like didn't
really know how to worked right but she
like didn't have a lot of followers I
was like okay like let's just write it
into the show or that you know I don't
know crazy so crazy crazy but you were
not in the end you saw that really
shocked probably um I wasn't shocked
because I had gone when we were doing
the boy and address stuff we had had
GLAAD come in to talk to her about you
know sort of how transgender when she
kind of didn't really know how
transgender or the like most up-to-date
hip sort of take on it right
you know like wasn't really on the right
side of history around it and we're like
you know let's just put it into the show
and Sara Gilbert is plays the mom and
she's you know lesbian she knows all
this stuff like we're gonna be you know
she'll make sure that everything's you
know that Rosie and understands and what
the kid on set but you know what I'm
sorry to answer your question
I was surprised if it had been like a
transphobic thing or like you know cuz
she's very into the Israel if it had
been about that or like the Nazi cookies
thing was a little bit like she's Jewish
and it's obviously offensive but like I
can see why she thought it was funny
right I understand on so I would never
do it I think that was a really bad
choice that she made and wasn't funny
but I understand why she thinks it was
okay to tweet mm-hmm but this I I am
shocked I have to say I'm still shocked
do you think ABC there's like they are
the ones who shut the show down like was
there another avenue in hindsight than
that let than to have all those people
lose their jobs
the PR people should have shut her
Twitter down ages ago I mean it's just
it's like it was a problem for a while
you know but it was kind of like such a
bummer but it was like she was like
retweeting [ __ ] about like brainwashing
an MKULTRA and Leia knows stuff it's
obviously she's like hey she um yes but
also it's like you have to understand
like you know and I'm not breaking news
here but like she's admitted to being
mentally ill right she'd admitted it
before so there was a lot of people were
like oh people know that she's and
they're not taking it seriously but then
when she started getting more influence
in the show did 25 million viewers and
was like huge it was like a lot of these
people don't know that they just assume
if Roseanne tweets it it must be true
right so then it started becoming like a
poisonous really irresponsible thing
because she's dead now as a million
followers and people are actually
listening to her again and they think
that what she's saying is true yes on a
computer and nothing that's on the
computer would be fake you know yeah do
you think like um that do you feel like
this is the first time I really talked
about this by the way really yeah it's
gonna get me in trouble
yeah no it's not gonna get in trouble
Mary why or not you're such a power I
think you're a leader really yeah that's
very nice
I don't thank you yeah I don't think
that you could you don't get I don't
think you could get in trouble I think
you decide what kind of figure out the
parameters and I think sometimes it's
like how does someone even be a
conservative it like I'll tell you
that's like I got Tollywood like I
always came to Hollywood because I
wanted to like I didn't like some of the
things I saw in my neighborhood you know
yeah like I didn't like there was a lot
of racism from black kids and white kids
you know I mean I would get yeah and I
would get in it so I was like I gotta
get out of here I gotta get out here
where people can't see past themselves
yeah yeah I'll get it get out of here
where people are on third-generation
welfare recipients and they don't want
to do anything I gotta get out of here
where somebody thinks just because
they're dumb that they want to keep
their kid out of school too so that the
kid doesn't surpass them in education
yeah so that they still feel like the
dad you know like yeah just all this
[ __ ] like some of this I got to get away
from yeah but then I get to Los Angeles
and it's like there's not even a
southern accent on television you know
it's like really Reba was it's so
interesting is nobody to represent but
don't
that's true see well that is also part
of the reason that you know angry so
just let me put it fascinating so how
angry I get when then wealthy celebrity
people tell me a direction that I need
to vote or some things that I need to
believe in and they don't even [ __ ]
have anybody to represent where I'm from
that's fastened it makes money it made
literally to me honestly made me it made
my whole like all the [ __ ] work and
stuff that I did to get through
Hollywood and navigate it made it feel
like I didn't exist
Wow and it just in that kind of stuff
hurt my feelings you know and I'm not
trying to tell you that I haven't really
you know thought about this I didn't
know is gonna feel so viscerally about
it but you know so I think a lot of
people feel that way and I notice a lot
of people I think a lot of people feel
very unseen by Hollywood as well and
very dismissed and Hillary that basket
of deplorable zit was [ __ ] over like
as soon as we're maligning you know I
mean I I'm not a political analyst so
obviously don't quote yeah but it was
like we are on this show either right
yeah we're calling them stupid we're
calling them backwards that's what I
felt like
and it's like no these people are
[ __ ] they you know working their
asses off and just want to be seen in
her and I think that that's part of who
I want to be you know involved in
Roseanne so badly because I wanted you
know marginalize people it's not even
marginalize this is the what's the
majority of people to be represented a
growing majority on television so that
they felt like okay I exist now I don't
have to vote in a way you know that I
feel like I exist right you know by this
guy the only guy that sees me the guy
that [ __ ] went to Wisconsin you know
the guy who was actually like you know
yeah you know so I was hoping that that
would reverse the exact thing that
you're talking about you know it wasn't
the south it was you know Lanford but
that's super interesting world and
here's the thing about myself i don't
feel like i'm not a redneck like yeah
I'm associate with any of that [ __ ] yeah
I don't have a bass boat you know mom
with my mother would occasionally listen
a Willie Nelson at night by herself you
know but um we didn't have any of that
like we weren't hunting I wouldn't doing
all that yeah but I just felt like a
poor like a rural white kid yeah yeah
and what shows did you watch growing up
I watched Roseanne wow that's it do we
watch Roseanne we watched and then we
watched by the way you realize I'm like
I get I'm sorry to cut you off no it's
okay go nuts when I'm making a TV show
with the set design
like when in the costume people like
when someone's character is trying to
get a job or unemployed they put him in
like Dior suits and I'm like this is
like this is so for just the set design
in general 2 broke girls I'm actually
really proud of it we actually it was
these girls it was nicer so we actually
made a set that looked like that's where
someone making $300 a week would live we
didn't put him in a mansion it reminded
me the diner that's that Roseann and
then worked in whenever it actually was
very much reminded me of that oh cool it
was a lot of it was inspired by Roseann
yeah yeah we were really trying to get
that right you know so it's like also
don't put a show on TV about low income
people and make it look like a goddamn
gala yeah you know and have them in it's
just feels fake and false well a lot of
television I notice as a viewer it's too
clear these days yeah and it's too tight
in its like it say that again a
different way it's too clear and I've
heard tons of people talk about this
it's too clear like clear like like
visually visually yeah okay by MTV yeah
I can't believe it if it's so clear and
which is interesting now that high-def I
was at someone's house the other day and
they were showing like some commercial a
rich person it was not a rich person Oh
David Spade I'm wrong area who actually
I got to talk to on the phone the other
day for the first time back just talk me
into being bad babies music video you
know that girl cast me outside yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's like I think you should
do it how do I get that gig I promise I
just had two days ago and it was
absolute assault was it amazing it was
so bizarre but let's finish this
conversation okay is she get him is she
the next card he be I don't know if I
can the funny thing was Fay goes look
she's she's a new Madonna well I'll be
working for her in ten years I was like
yeah she's the new Laura Ingalls Wilder
[Laughter]
but I want to finish this conversation
maybe this is interesting and I think it
is important I agree ya know and I was
thinking about it like you know someone
asked me I was doing like a Q&A like for
a book that I wrote a book and what it's
called it's called I'm fine in other
lies it came out the same day as the
biggest shooting didn't do a lot of
press obviously uh there I mean you
cannot promote anything anymore because
the Newt would the way the news cycle
goes you can't like literally the Vegas
journey hop in that morning I can't go
on the Today Show be like guys my 20s
was really hard I have advice for you
but honestly in some of the in some of
like your key search words SEO search
words that you put Vegas shooting in
your
I don't even know you're saying for any
advertisements what is I don't know it's
like saying if somebody's gonna look up
Vegas like Vegas should I come up that
on the side somewhere like a possible
shooting you might also like Whitney's
self-help bug Vegas shooting did you
mean Whitney Cummings yeah and and that
that was my joking I'll take responsible
for that that's not we're not making fun
of the biggest shooting dude no but I
just mean like you can't like it's just
everything's so horrific now that it's
like hard to you know but anything you
would argue we need to laugh more than
ever and whatever by my but comes at it
yeah but no is it a QA and when you do a
book QA people ask like super you know
interesting questions and someone asked
me why aren't there any right-wing
political comedians why isn't there a
right-wing Bill Maher I mean I guess you
can't be these days but but why doesn't
the right have one I mean there's the
Blue Collar Comedy guys I don't think
they really talk about how you won't
work anywhere even though there's an
audience you won't work oh well here's
Russell you can't get an agent or you
the clubs won't book you yeah well you
can't work in huh no one's even gonna
talk to you but but you couldn't say
like you look what out even just like I
don't I don't disagree I just I don't
read and thought it through and but
imagine that like imagine if you are
conservative
have your opinion opinion right there
are people out there who would trust you
could be you could have voted for
somebody and also not be really give a
[ __ ] about him right but why are there
no is this somebody why are there no
seem Youssef isn't it Nick de Paul he's
gotten super right-wing know and I think
that it's it's it's hurt him
right and then there's also he kind of
went off over the deep end but Owen
Benjamin yeah yo it's too far out there
everyone's out doing
I was just looking Owens kind of like
well I think he seems like Roseanne's
son a little bit but out in the woods
no but is any like men's rights activist
or a white power active mr. zaimes
probably spreading rumors but it's
gotten a little bit bizarre it's also
like trashing comics like get out of
here yeah it's just gotten I think some
of it's gotten a little bit some
desperation that happens when you aren't
here but I'll say this like I was so
nervous like I feel I've felt know I've
felt intimidated to be where I'm from by
this industry I bet I've felt and that's
scary what the [ __ ] is a fascinating
here's the thing and also people look
down on you
yeah and like I don't know but then you
know what's funny is as soon as like I
started getting fans in the past two
months all these agents sneaking up on
me here slipped me their cards money
isn't law I'll say that to you whatever
your money isn't loyal no one gives a
[ __ ] so it's like that's what I'm saying
they do though you they don't even take
a meeting with you if you say you have
but if you start a podcast like what
you're doing right here right where
you're from and talking about even if
you're making fun of Trump but if you're
conservative and you get the kind of
numbers and Asians gonna represent you
if it's gonna put money in the bank
right that's the thing money isn't oil
and that's why I think how after how
many people do you think are Blake
Shelton must have gotten every offer in
the world in the past six months for
people trying to connect with the other
audience and reaching out can you
imagine the millions of dollars just
thinking are you just country what I
must woman that's what I'm sure that's
what Hollywood thinks they don't know
you have no avenues what's their avenue
even in to be like where's Brad Paisley
yeah he wears a cowboy hat they're so
alienated I'm sure but yeah you feel so
alienated standing is coming back I
heard it is that what it's called the
Tim Allen show good good for him doing
the Tim Allen for him guy even [ __ ]
thinks about you know all two things
about him out first of all I opened for
him like eight years seven or eight
years ago at the lab when he was doing
something and I went on stage I was
bombing and I like didn't know why
because I was like that should have gone
better like at the Laugh Factory do well
and it was all trucker hats and then he
went onstage and he was doing tons like
pro-gun stuff oh oh that's like his it
was different audience yeah but he leans
into that right no and I was like I'm an
empowered woman and everyone's like
we're good right
um but yeah he leans into that in his
stand-up and also I live in Tim Allen's
old house not like a recent one like
before home improvement it's not like
crazy man it's not like some crazy
mansion it's uh I love it it's four
bedrooms it's like it's got land I have
dogs and I see him one day at Starbucks
and I said uh Wow hey man and at the
time we had shows and we were shooting
next to each a man
the handle on that one toilets kind of
loose yeah how do you deal with that I
was like hey this is so weird but I I I
live in your old house and he was like
oh the one on Ridgely I was like no that
not that when the water in Mars like he
has not his
50 [ __ ] houses knows like like when
you were doing pilot season like that
house the house that you were like
memorizing lines in and I was like oh no
up on I'm not going to say my address
thank you but I was like you know this
house three six three three and he was
like oh god that place is such a
[ __ ] I was like that's my house okay
like it's my dream home like for me it's
a mansion I love it
he's like it's the pool still
overflowing into the living room and I
was like no one told me that [ __ ] an
inspection like I have to pay extra for
that now you know he builds houses so he
had done a bunch of work on it and then
I had this one have you ever done family
constellation work no it's this thing
where basically this person figures out
like what you're talking a new church
and edex no I'm good it's like the
offshoot of Scientology it's cheaper and
they figure out like what epigenetics
from your ancestors you're carrying in
your genes in your DNA because when we
have trauma happened to us it encodes
into our DNA and it expresses itself
through us okay like if you show a baby
a picture of a spider it'll freak out
even though it's never actually seen a
spider
Wow comes built into their grandparents
saw a spider net exactly right that's
what used to kill baby rice bug bites
are there were there their father was
got scared during arachnophobia yeah
it's John Goodman or like your
imagination and then yeah and then a
phobia if you have a like a mouse mm-hmm
smell they did this study where they had
a mouse smell cherry blossoms and every
time they'd smelled the cherry blossom
they'd electrocute it and the offspring
of a mouse when it smelled cherry
blossom it would get scared and run away
you know it's like an evolutionary thing
that we do yeah so I'm I am I tired oh
so she figures out like what happened in
your past and like all this stuff and I
learned a bunch of crazy stuff about my
ancestors and stuff that they did and
it's so linked to what I'm doing today
it's super interesting but anyway she
also was like there's something wrong
with this house like that's your home
yeah there's like bad energy in this
house and like it was Tim Allen
Tim Helena and apparently some rappers
flooded the pool
ghosts are like in my house but yeah it
definitely seems like there's no like I
wish they made a Hollywood that's for
everybody people like Ron Weitzman
around like I don't even know right
right each anymore but I'm sure you
right so there's some people I think
when they do they have planes right I
agree these days you can't even you
can't even well first of all half of it
you couldn't say that yeah you couldn't
say I voted for Donald Trump and work
out here you know you just couldn't say
it
Roseanne could and then she just
couldn't right yeah well she even and
there's something else about Roseanne if
you even go back and look like it
grabbing the cross spitting there's this
thing to you know not only to pinch but
then the [ __ ] turn like there's two
types people that pinch you there's a
[ __ ] person that pinches you and then
there's that [ __ ] and sometimes
they're Italian
yeah and they [ __ ] pinch you and they
turn it but here's what I saying I think
Roseanne and III I don't totally get
this cuz I think that as comics we all
want to be loved you know ultimately we
just want attention and love and
acceptance yeah I think she I don't know
there are some people from what I
understand that like need their outside
to match their insides like they can't
receive love yeah and when they start
receiving love they have to [ __ ] it up
or they I've done that in relationships
before oh yeah I loves me too like I
gotta [ __ ] it up or make him hate me
somehow because that's like my
equilibrium like I'm other wise I'm just
always waiting for the other shoe to
drop and it makes me super anxious when
things are going too well
cuz think about it the two times that
she sabotage herself with her racist
[ __ ] is she was first wasn't the day the
numbers came out 25 million viewers she
fired off that Nazi tweet she retweeted
the like the parklands survivors were
actors like just totally self-sabotage
not all of them were my argument about
that is like I've auditioned child
actors if there were any actors that
were that good they'd be on show we'd
have them like they said someone their
aunt Coulter said that about the kids in
cages at the border like if an actor
could cry on cue at 5 it would have nine
Oscars what are you talking about and by
the way you realize that child actors
have [ __ ] stage moms with them at all
times like they can only work four hours
at a time every six days they have to
have like a two
it's hard to keep powder on somebody
cheeks I think bullets going in the
distance and so on but then the racist
tweet she set was the day the writers
room started on season two it's like any
time love starts to creep in it's like
shadow just like cut it off right oh
that's interesting yeah any time like
there's yeah and I think that goes back
to something where she's just not she's
not in she's not sure of what's going on
with herself and she doesn't because
it's like there's a certain point where
like you gotta get help
we all do and it's just silly it's like
you have this minute like [ __ ] no
Twitter for you you know no Twitter for
you first of all the only people that
are on Twitter just rat but you
comedians are on there sharing like it's
some stuff what have to surround
yourself with people that call you on
your [ __ ] right and let you know and she
just she's scared so many people away
people are so scared of her that it's
like she does actually Handler kind of
oh I don't know but in like a different
way oh really
but um but so what about this though
like and also then for the Hollywood the
Hollywood's like well we have to be so
diverse but then armor weren't
african-americans and black people
begging him get him Academy Awards like
two years ago an Oscar easy [ __ ] where a
UH what the [ __ ] like a it's like
suddenly you're the most diverse thing
in the world when you know and there's
just I don't know sometimes it's just so
like yeah and it's like people are like
[ __ ] Donald Trump that guy's a piece of
[ __ ] but then the head mogul of the
Hollywood is a [ __ ] I just guys coming
in [ __ ] Potter who you know who
Weinstein I don't I mean the [ __ ] Trump
stuff is so so many people have
alienated their audiences by that
because it's all so hacky like I don't
what to do to fail because you runs our
country right now what are you it's like
going up at the Tonys and saying [ __ ]
Trump talk about preaching is acquired
like no one who voted for hims gonna beg
he makes a good point
yeah like what you're just cuz you know
that um it's a safe space to do it it's
all just [ __ ] up like it's like it's
snooping and it's not flying high at all
and it doesn't move the needle and it
doesn't actually victimizes him because
I was actually talking you know Ron
Funches yeah
he kind of blew my mind the other day
because he said that a sweet guy yeah
cuz we're talking about members Jimmy
Fallon got so much [ __ ] for you know
ruffling his and being nice to tribe and
everyone said that they like it hit that
appearance humanized him and
it's not Jimmy Fallon's fault like we
were all doing it you know we were all
making jokes about him I did the Trump
roast and was like in what we were kind
of doing is making him a victim I'm
making everyone go Oh Hollywood beats up
on him we don't like Hollywood because
it's a bunch of pretentious rich people
they can't relate to us they don't give
a [ __ ] about us so we're on his side and
he became the underdog Oh make it shows
we were constantly making fun of him and
Ron was like yeah I feel bad he made
like a Funny or Die video based on his
book we were all doing his roast like we
thought we were taking him down but we
were actually kind of building it up him
up and we didn't know it right oh I
think I feel bad I mean I bet if you
look bad I don't know what Trump's life
is like you know but I mean half of the
half of Hollywood was friends with him
you know until the 91 or whatever but
it's like so it's all just seemed like
so I think people are a lot more a lot
smarter than people give him credit
people can be fans of comments so they
don't agree with politically I don't
know why I'm even asking them no this is
a good question do I think that people
can be fans of comics that they don't
agree with politically yes I do
yeah because I know that I am yeah cuz
right now it's gotten so intense like
you know I was reading this thing about
like if you want someone to agree with
you you have to empathize with them
first because we are wired to like so if
I say to you hey Theo what's the fastest
way to get back to Studio City I think
it's the 405 right and if you say to me
it's not the four or five it's Sepulveda
right I'm gonna actually believe more
strongly that it's the 405 there's that
woman Maria Popova again wrote about it
in my book quoting her I put the study
in there because I'm so fascinated by
this so if you want someone to agree
with you you have to empathize with them
for the FBI does to get secrets out of
killers and right so if you say if I say
I think four or five the fastest if you
go Whitney I know why you would think
that I used to think that I used to but
now I took some poll data and it's so
much faster like as long as you
empathize with me you have to I have to
feel seen by you first right oh yeah
yeah I drove that ton of times and I
would feel that way a lot and then one
day I went with someone and they show me
this way and you might try that it's
it's different and they have a great
place to get a [ __ ] coconut water
thank you so much yeah and you'd
probably pretty driving on that Street
no thank you or funny and pretty and
funny or just funny or empowered but
like you see
Oh have you changed your behavior since
all this I went in the comedy store the
other day and I can't remember what
comic it was actually do but I'm not
going to tell you he came to hug me in
any way oh sorry we can't do that
anymore yeah oh Jesus don't make me
don't well your don't seem like that I
think there's some kunti women let you
be around in this like their whole thing
is based on that oh really oh I think so
like I've been I'll be at some parties
it's just like oh it's just like come on
like because here's the thing outside of
Los Angeles everybody's pretty much
doing things ok it feels like yeah it's
just when you get here well cuz there's
so much power and money here and the
yeah and all the pilots although all the
articles all the publications yeah are
liberally so there's no even that was it
thing biggest thing about that like out
of the gate I remember when Trump was
run I was like this is gonna [ __ ] win
out of the gate I was like this dude's
gonna [ __ ] win just be good well
here's what I knew cuz I'm a regular I'm
a person that I I just I was sitting
there and I could listen him I didn't
think he's a cool / I've always hated
politicians dude all of them are
egomania authenticity I mean just became
the new cool thing like I remember
before like wouldn't Ben Carson was that
his name would still only be black
that's what I call them really no cuz
you just fell asleep all the time dude
yeah I'm sleepy white but like when it
was like you know it was like a bunch of
people and he was debating them I
remember the sound was off there was no
thought in my mind that Trump would ever
win cuz that's just to Rueter crest
right and I watched him and he called
every one of the candidates out the
Republican candidates running against
him and he went you've asked me for
money and you've asked me for money Cuba
and something happened where it was like
a primal instinct where I was like yep I
like that guy if there's a fire I'm
following him like a primordial instinct
of like that's the Alpha right and I
think we like you that's the Alpha so
when he's lying I don't think anyone
gives a [ __ ] that he's lying his base
doesn't care all politicians lie so it's
we're so used to it my man no flagrant
about it they just it just translated
them as fearless like he doesn't give a
[ __ ]
for him I'm [ __ ] with that guy I'm
not scared of anything that translates
into our amygdala like if the buildings
on fire these people are gonna be
[ __ ] like like fake trying to figure
out where sorry
is my fault this is your fault I know
you know whose fault this what like
pre-scripted [ __ ] he's just like get the
[ __ ] out of here and so I kind of on
some level understand from like a
reptile brain why that was appealing
right and that's different America like
there's different Americas I've never
before in my life and I felt like
there's two different Americas like
there's an America where like yeah like
having a gun in Beverly Hills dude [ __ ]
no I don't sell me a gun I don't want to
see a gun but if I go back to like maybe
some of the neighborhood's I grew up in
or some of the areas I was around dude
if I'm riding through New Orleans
somebody says man they're at the rental
car company we can put a gun under your
seat for an extra $70 in a thing I'll be
like no but I'd like put that thing
under the [ __ ] seat I've had to to my
to my black friends murdered in New
Orleans in the past 20 years right like
just like some places are just but here
I guns but they wouldn't have died if
they had guns of their own someone would
have died right somebody would have done
whatever murder by the gun under their
seat at the rental car place right but
out of my fear right here no way I would
never say heavy guns
oh no I I wish they could you think less
people will die if more people have guns
that logic no it's so crazy
no but I think that if I think one day
Elon Musk is gonna put a gun magnet the
sky and they're all gonna go right up
there and just assume to it and we'll be
kidding but it'll I think seven cars
also well [ __ ] it something guys you
guys look just select Toyotas and some
of them need to go okay but um but
here's the thing but I could understand
how people there say oh I need to have
my gun you know as opposed to because
it's scary yeah I remember living in a
place with my sister man and uh and I
had a gun and I didn't tell my sister
that I had it and I would not have slept
without it because it was just too
difficult like I had a protector yeah
she had a dog but the dog had mental
health issues my whole family's ever
come walk me through that so I mean this
is boil a nerdy state under the bed
forever dude I mean he just yeah but
here's the thing what I say is yeah here
I would never even think of having a gun
it would be weird if somebody did yeah
if you bizarre somebody show me a gun
buy it but in other places it's doesn't
people live in two different worlds like
here diversity sure it's comfortable its
comfortable people are educated more
than levels of interaction yeah dude in
it places that I grew up in or other
places
it's a different [ __ ] world it's not
so our brain changes when we are in
scarcity or fear like money you have the
more fear you have and then you start
objective it's a good point and
maligning people as enemies yes
you know you know the stakes get way
higher it's early hills everyone's got
money no one's gonna try to steal from
you right you know but when you get to a
place where there's limited resources oh
yeah and then people are stealing and
suddenly the first person that stole
from you if there were a different color
skin or they look different races all of
us yes then you're it's like I mean it's
[ __ ] up man yeah some of it is so
[ __ ] up but I think the solution is in
for me it seems like how our education
system how we don't teach kids how to
accept other kids and how to like
spelling I don't give a [ __ ] if I kick
and spell a computer can do that now
like I care if you my son knows how to
accept somebody else are recognized if
their friend is like hurting like things
like that seems so should we go back to
the fact that you don't care if your kid
can spell yeah I just don't agree past
that and just I feel like we should
spend some more time on that it's super
important that you can't spell he's
definitely gonna be communicating with
guns I feel like you can't throw that
around and expect it to just slide under
but on some real [ __ ] like that's not
that's not yeah but yeah I mean to get
in that kind of stuff I just yeah I just
feel alienated by Hollywood I felt like
I guess I got spent so much time and I'm
not allowed here I think that you have
to like it's interesting because it's
like also most people don't know how
they know the major celebrity so they
say that if you're the average of if
you're a huge fan with your favorite
show my favorite shows probably two
Broke Girls which is in syndication now
right yeah and Dateline to know yeah so
what's your favorite just give me any TV
show oh my favorite show probably right
now is uh I like Ozark I guess Ozark so
Ozark is your favorite show on average
if someone has a favorite show they
watch three episodes Wow correct
that's a Hugh
fan of a show okay hit yeah so most
people don't even know who's on their
favorite show when it's on where it's on
most people don't know half the
celebrities that we think are famous
that were jealous of on Instagram most
people aren't even on their radar
stories like oh these Hollywood people
that are representing all this elitist
shits like most people don't even know
who these people are right much less
give a [ __ ] about what they think right
so it's like they say that with the exit
polling on all of this stuff we were so
off because the exit polling companies
didn't call homes with landlines right
they didn't call landlines they only
call people with cell phones and that in
itself is elitist cuz there's some
people that don't even have cell phones
oh yeah we just pretended they didn't
exist yeah you know oh yeah like that's
how [ __ ] far off we are we did focus
groups for Roseanne because I was so
worried that like a bunch of rich white
people in a room writing for people with
living resources was just gonna come off
insane and we did focus group testing
with a bunch of women and what we
thought was important to them was so
[ __ ] off wow we were so wrong
literally like they asked a question
they were like so do you feed your kids
organically could you try to buy organic
food for your kids and they were like
like real food they're like what are you
talking about yeah like we were crazy
yeah yeah no time for that
none and actually race like I don't know
III don't have statistics on this but
it's also like race everyone had
interracial families and relationships
stuff it was like there was actually way
less racism beige power that's my mom
you know cuz it's all gonna it worried
so if we're back we're headed quickly to
beige you know there so that's where I'm
trying to be at the finish line and I
think everybody's just gonna be so
diverse soon but yeah it's just while I
felt like man all these people writing
these articles they're all from New York
or LA and they don't know some of the
things do you feel seen by is there
anyone that like people listeners look
first thing honestly the listeners from
are from the podcast a little bit oh
other comedian feel seen or heard by
them that are listening to you that just
downloaded your thing no I mean he'll
see you heard about him I guess I don't
know I don't know just recently like
people have started to like seem
interested in my comedy I guess yeah so
I don't know who I feel seen a her by
for the first time my life I think I
start to feel a little bit by myself
yeah yeah you know just kind of
comforting did you feel like when you
came to Hollywood you had to kind of
like change yourself out ah yeah I think
pretended I think I pretended like I was
a there were times I pretended like I
was a redneck or I felt like that's the
only thing we were like I gotta lean
into Who I am so strongly to be uniquely
awesome Mencia [ __ ] like Oh sarcasm my
whole first special it's all a it's all
Sark a it's the whole thing is this art
is it's like it's like a sarcasm it's
like um well our first specials are
always just like oh it's like felt
someone filming us losing our virginity
or something like there's no way I
someone sent me a clip of my first
special I'm literally just screaming I'm
screaming jokes at these innocent people
who just we're trying to see a comedy
I'm like ah I wearing bright pink
lipstick because I was I just didn't
know who I was yet and I was like this
little me you know I had bought a shirt
online there was a bedazzled t-shirt
because I was so afraid of looking to
fans oh I was afraid of looking so I
wanted to like appeal but it hat was
head like rhinestones on it so it's like
oh it's like the lights are hitting I
knew nothing about how anything worked I
was wearing bell-bottoms and New
Balances with Velcro I was so lost as a
person cialis flared up again because I
waited till the clapping finish just
start my next joke because I didn't
understand that I can I had a microphone
that could talk over the clavicle so I
look like such a [ __ ] narcissist like
I look like a dictator I'm just like
waiting for everyone to finish clapping
and then it gets quiet I'm like now
let's start my next joke like I look
like I'm milking the laughs but I just
didn't realize I could talk
simultaneously guys you know powerful
that probably made you see him in
hindsight I've been really low in
control I look crazy wait so they're not
like I also like was so afraid of
getting heckled back then then I'd be
like oh sure my jokes so fast like I
just didn't understand actually I've got
really good advice from Pauly Shore
right before I shot my first special he
called me and he was like do one taping
and do the jokes like you've never done
them before like changed the inflection
change a word change the order or
something like to keep it free because
you know but yeah so [ __ ] I am you
type your spell or shoot your special
it's all typed up and you know what
you're doing and you're kind of just
going through the motions and phoning it
in but it like lacks like a little bit
of heart beat and soul and he told me to
do that no I can't change it I'm filming
it like this is and it really made a
difference yeah so it would've been even
worse how do you know he is
that's what I Paulie huh you forget
house you don't forget but he has the
weazy you know he has this kind of
hunger yes such a smart guy yeah I mean
it's actually really kind of amazing
like when people trying to make fun of
him it's like teaming if you just watch
his act he's making fun of himself yeah
hard to make fun of someone who's self
deprecation Oh like admits you choice
funeral he was being so fun yeah I was
there was so good yeah I was Argus [ __ ]
my leg all these people [ __ ] my mom
like it was just like Jimmy super it's
like I didn't yeah like great like you
know that's interesting I know I think
you're such a powerful woman I think you
call all the shots it seems like you
know what I don't know I don't see that
at all I feel like Instagram models are
crushing me I see people that like make
jewelry that have 17 million followers
and like that's true you know it's like
Instagram just changed the game right
there's girls that take pictures of
their yogurt every morning Oh like bad
baby dude I was thinking about bad baby
you the other day alter her mom yeah now
she's a millionaire dude that's the new
yeah you know so notoriety is the new
fame so I guess I feel like I finally
had figured out how to do this business
and then it just [ __ ] changed
overnight and I was like I'm now like
I'm no clue how it works
Wow yeah it do another like business he
got into like the because you know like
do you think it would be something else
kind of like or a world that you get
into and I know you love animals and
stuff like that but do you think there
would be people think I'm such a crazy
like animal but I am but there's such a
sense of justice with animals you know
and there's not always in our world so
there's something really comforting
about the predictability and it's sort
of like you know being able to reason
with something you can reason with an
animal much more clear than you can with
a human yeah animals don't know how to
lie yeah they don't care what you do for
a living
yeah it's like I literally just hang out
with animals because they're not like so
what are you working on yeah I just
think it's two hours where no one's
asking you like why did your show get
canceled like it's just like a nice
respite so many people love you that's
one thing about you yeah people say like
that's nice I have no idea how I'm
perceived and I always think everybody
doesn't like me then that's my [ __ ] but
it is nice to hear that sometimes it's
nice to tell people how they're
perceived yeah yeah at least some might
think to make them feel even if it just
is to is to make them feel okay but no I
think people always people always like
speak like admirably um you know what's
interesting it's like like ask me if a
fake comic is funny not a real name okay
is uh Lawrence Arabia funny
Lawrence Arabia is the nicest guy yeah
so like when people respond about your
character like that's what it's like
people to me like sometimes I'll see
people in the hallway or something or
comments because you work so hard like
that's just like a weird compliment
right you know what I mean like you
really hustle like I remember like I
used to come onstage in the beginning
and people like you are a great writer
yeah like but not performing like I
always find the insult in any compliment
you know but it's just like I'm always I
love just picking apart people's
backhanded compliments cuz comics are so
good at figuring out a way to compliment
you without right you know not even it's
almost a natural thing cuz comics can't
say people are funny if they're not they
can't they refuse yeah even if they are
funny they're reluctant to do it right
so that's why if you ever ask someone if
someone's funny and they don't think so
they like super nice guy what's really
yeah just have a nice yeah yeah like
anything oh the guy the tribe's did you
love that guy super yeah
Aries yeah by the way backhanded
compliments when you come onstage those
are my favorite thing oh yeah like or
like when you come offstage and
someone's like a weird crowd or before
you go on they're like great crowd it's
just the crowds great so it's so weird
how we felt like it comics no matter
what like we like we have to communicate
something to people on stage I think
almost at all times in a weird way it's
like we can't let a moment pass where
there's an opportunity to communicate
that is so fun that's true and
exhausting at a point that is so true
it's very exhausting and I feel like I
owe something to everyone all the time
even though no one's interested I'm like
I'm like hey man what do you buy I'm
like I'm at Trader Joe's please no one's
interested sounds like the best name for
a special no one's every one so obsessed
with themselves now yeah that's what I
used to
recognize so much more like it's weird I
was like am I not does no one care like
but everyone's everyone's their own
celebrity now yeah we starting to
cherish ourselves I was uh who is this
by the way this is uh Chris Farley oh
yeah first of all it's not Donald Trump
it's looks like me you have a huge
Donald Trump or Drake could you have get
on it all but yeah it's pretty cool
maybe he'll come one day and but yeah it
was so crazy he called me the other day
I called him I got his number from the
directors like call Spade he just did it
with bad baby you know and next thing
you know I was talking to him he's like
one of my idols I thought Joe Dirt was a
documentary dude when I first saw it I
was young so I remember thinking it was
like all about orphans and people
getting left at the Grand Canyon his
[ __ ] and so when I first saw him I was
like dude how many like you know orphans
reached out to you after you did that
movie I've actually not seen that he's
like what the [ __ ] you talking about I
was like about kids getting left behind
by their parents he's like none nobody
thought that was a documentary yeah
that's crazy
you haven't seen it Joe - I've never
seen Joe Dirt I know it feels like a
weird thing to watch for the first time
I watch you watch that I think hey where
would I even like think can you reopen a
block restart your company so I get a
joker what does it called GPS VHS yeah
chief I'm not sure but yeah Beach s
state is the nice paid it's a great at
like he's just such a nice dude yeah
have you ever heard the story about what
his assistant tried to kill him oh you
gotta look that up it's good I think you
told the whole story on Howard Stern
Andy yeah it's [ __ ] harrowing and
amazing yeah
and it's like I remember hearing that
story and being like do I really want to
like do this like get oh I see get this
level of popularity I wouldn't I'm not
as like I'm not spayed alright so he's
so famous and he was he's a movie star
you know but I'm just I just remember
going like what are we what are we
trying to get why do I think Fame is
gonna fix everything
yeah when your assistant tries to kill
you it just makes you rethink like what
are we doing I was sorry he's a pale
Selina
that's what I feel is kind of a little
bit i was just googling the woman they
killed Selina
she died in prison apparently I'm
obsessed with that case and I'm obsessed
with the Jenna
for Lopez I could see you playing a
taller Selena kind of really no you
can't I've made it in Russia crane yeah
in Ukraine on stage arena that's my I
feel like that Donald p.m. just hit a
new level in my brain um no I forgot oh
did you ever hear Bill Murray on Howard
talk about Fame because he hates Fame so
much and he said try getting rich and
see if you still need to be famous
hmm right get rich first and that's
right so maybe his dad he's like I tried
so hard my whole life to get famous when
I realized I really just want to be rich
well I didn't want to be famous could
you give me famous and not rich right
because you can be rich and yours free
from some things but with Fey me you're
not free famous has Pilate knows a
famous entrapment it's the opposite you
know and I just thought that was so
interesting and a friend of mine wrote
an article on that I'm from
mispronounces Souza that's a the female
rapper sza is that I'd renounce it says
he didn't she'd an article my friend
that I went to college with his Lizzy
Goodman she wrote that book meet me in
the bathroom she's amazing music
journalist and she was talking to some
manager who was saying something about
how trying to get famous is a mental
illness I don't know which one right all
of it you know but there's there's
something so good I could see that I
could see that I think so bizarre about
it right I mean you know it's so funny I
asked myself like just recently like a
you know been selling out shows and like
selling out like weekends and it's just
been kind of crazy I haven't had that
experience amazing and it's kind of like
when you're stand-up you get to see
humans you get to see them laugh at you
you get to meet them you get to take
pictures with them but to be famous and
removed from the people that's like you
so scary it's bizarre I want you to all
know who I am give me your money but I'm
gonna hide behind this fortress and
you're never get to actually see me
we're actually out in the trenches like
meeting the people that like us you know
that's why I think we're pioneer I think
right now there's no better time to be a
comedian
people say it's harder you can't say
this you can't say that I think that
people are so desperate right now for
anybody to seem just to say what they
really [ __ ] mean yeah I think
everybody's on [ __ ] drugs
everybody's on some kind of drug
everybody's scared of how they look
everybody's you
who says you can't say anything now I
mean that you can write be smart about
it yeah so that you're bulletproof right
right but it's tough because here's the
problem is what do you say something and
it's just sometimes if we just get down
to what the exact set three or four
words people say yeah and we tend then
we have no conversation you know like
I'm liking it back to 16 and pregnant
whatever that shows when they had 70
kids living in the house the Christian
family right though and one touch
somebody there was a rumor there was
something that happened one of them like
when they were 15 touched like a one of
his sisters yeah yeah yeah or something
and they shut the show down and I'm like
this is theirs first of all the 17 kids
in a house yeah I can't [ __ ] just a
LightSwitch child hitting a [ __ ]
resident yeah incorrect
okay sorry sorry but you can't probably
you know it's hard to open a window with
that accidentally brush in the back so
he's lived okay so like it's very hard
to do yeah but that's when they shut the
show down when that's when I thought
this is when we can learn so much we're
in the middle of a mass shaming because
now you don't even touch to a bacterial
about something their family I reveal
how do you know it's an accident or it
will be if a kid got molested the show
should go away they should stop getting
money okay so our sons gotta go to jail
right to them that's what he came to do
is money but I think the family figured
it out but it was like that's what these
cover [ __ ] up all the time yeah I guess
that's why kids get molested because I
guess is why it hide things you know we
do have to get to a points from as a
society that we're not making pedophiles
and rapists millionaire I agree it's
it's just not necessary
yeah there's too many yeah I agree I
guess it should have been like I want to
hear this conversation like what
happened here I want that's what I want
to see the show so putting children on
television is already child abuse
what they're doing is already abusive to
the kids that's it I agree you know ii
mean so it's like that shows got to go
regardless yeah it's yeah it's not good
for kids
yeah it doesn't end I mean it's not
consensual they don't have any consent
of that so to me the kind of person who
puts their infants on television of
course they're do another creepy gross
[ __ ] like that's a judgment issue that's
someone that doesn't have a good
judgment and if shady [ __ ] is going on
which it does in most most girls are
molested at some point in their lives
yeah like I don't believe that they will
handle it responsibly because they also
objected by their kids by putting on top
of it that's a good point
yeah it's like what's it like what's to
say that
the families is then going to hold up
their side of things and I guess for me
also freaked out about all this [ __ ]
it's just like why is it such a big loss
for you to lose the bad people you
there's so many good people out there
give them the money
give them the show you know I think it's
just about like I don't want to say
draining the swamp I feel like that's a
trump slogan now but it's really just
like cleaning house yeah like the rotten
apples just gotta go change is good I
think change it you know sometimes it
comes in forms that we don't know change
its progress right you know I think it's
actual project but it's hard to have one
I feel like without sometimes having the
it's hard sometimes you have to have
something else yeah like baby's going
out with the bathwater you mean yeah
literally that's what that show should
be called babies in dirty bathwater yeah
we play one question that came in from
and no this is just we put on our damn
feed yesterday that we would be in
studio
hey guys Nash from Cincinnati Ohio you
started ever done yeah
sorry what's a mash I love that I'm
squishing around this like I don't think
I can just do that yeah well I'm told
that I really did see about basic [ __ ] I
told you that all right hi hey guys Nash
from Cincinnati Ohio I just want to know
with me what do you think of the mullet
because I think that [ __ ] this I love it
I love your haircut I'm such a fan I
like it is really yeah it is so good
with your face oh thank you I love you I
love it and it's such a powerful it is
just so it works and it is so it's
gender-neutral you know that yes and no
yes and no but because it they're only
reasons not is on a woman she'd be
unfuckable because of our social
constructs and on a guy it's like not
only does it look good on you and is it
completely super flattering it's also
like this guy gives no [ __ ] this is
some alpha [ __ ] yeah it's very alpha you
know once I started growing my hair
first of all because people were like oh
people don't like gave you where you're
from and I was like we've been wearing
women's haircuts means I [ __ ] sat
next to and got my haircut growing up
count to nine
yeah I don't I'm not totally sure how it
comes together like there's no plan with
nothing pomade situation is if anything
like I'm so curious if there's like a
dry shampoo or is there a is this like a
hot oil is there there might be a vo5
sure oh it's all but the back is all
them up at Michael's craft there is
there is there is a very mysterious
process involved in it like can people
touch it
oh yeah yeah it's paddle dude in so many
[ __ ] raccoons come out when I'm
outside my yard mind joking dude so any
about that one creeper thing that's
always in the recycling bin who the [ __ ]
is that it's a green get your kid
yeah what about one more the audio calls
that came in Nick that was good
we'll do one more Winnie and then we'll
say thank you so much for your time hey
this question is for Whitney she could
hook up with one current Comedy Store
comedian a regular together with that
they just have sex with or it's another
goal is this to have sex
dude quit stalking her first of all or
continue stocking bang Add to Cart
download Michelle Joey Diaz maybe would
be good I love Joey dia is this just
have sex with there's just like marry
there's nothing you can mean anymore I
think these days it just means that a
hookup to me means like the one I want
to marry the [ __ ] out of here
so sad as sad as that I don't do that I
like I was with I was like played so
well like they have a good credit score
I love Joey Diaz that's feel so weird
because it feels like incest to me like
comics to me right so platonic to say
even a platonic husband ship that you
had to be into someone with oh god this
is gonna get me in trouble I feel it
Bryan Callen Wow I mean Bryan makes me
laugh right oh yeah Bryan makes me laugh
he
has this gift it's almost like you ever
seen Tinkerbell like um it's like Tinker
Bell's like inside of him you know like
you know Robin Hood has Tinker Bell you
know what it is it's like Robin Hood oh
yeah yeah there'd that Peter Pan yeah
that's on their shoulder he's just
always like yeah he's always ready like
he doesn't even [ __ ] sleep it's like
he just hides behind a piece of isil's
like a jester yes you know he's like I
you know I think that a big part of
being a comic by the way I do did have a
self tanner Fiasco so I'm worried people
are looking at my hand
nobody can see us I hear like this isn't
recording you [ __ ] idiot I think such
a big part of being a stand-up is making
the audience feel like they're safe with
you right right like they're in good
hands
right you know and when you trip up or
you're like looking at your notes all of
a sudden they're like oh like this
person might not know what they're doing
they might not be in control yeah like
they might have a sense of doubt like
right when you start giving the audience
power yeah that's what people like oh
you guys don't think that's funny
whatever I'm always like don't do that
because then you're giving them power
yeah and then all of a sudden the the
curtain has been pulled away and they're
in charge yeah you work for them now
right and kalyn when you're around Cal
and you're just like ah I know I'm not
gonna do any work right yeah he's just
gonna [ __ ] do gymnastics he's
planking yeah his dicks out he's like
hey you know you doing pull-ups like he
does I know that I can just sit on the
bench
yeah his dicks I was doing Romeo and
Juliet I remember he's doing an
impression of a bird
he's on hanging from the ceiling he's
spider now he's an endangered species
like I could just get to go on a
vacation I don't have to even have a
conversation because he's gonna do some
[ __ ] vagina monologue like I just
have to do it's just the so I could live
with someone like that where I feel like
I do I'm just being served me too I
could be in it I could be in a platonic
three-way marriage with you and Bryan
Callen who would you would you date have
you ever dated comic no Schumer and I
dated for a little bit that's true yeah
I didn't know that yes she and I did
write for a movie came out and it wasn't
I don't know yeah between us on a
Sabbats didn't fit didn't she didn't
leave it i didn't know i didn't have
trust in her like she always liked one
of me see you a boyfriend and girlfriend
exclusive i don't
oh I don't know I felt like I just was
like at a certain point I felt like was
a little bit of like a puppet kind of
like kind of just like a little sex
puppet you know is that like every guy's
dream but it wasn't my dream no you know
kind of I don't think I did it but she
used like this I she didn't use what we
talked about like this bigger idea like
this bigger kind of thing you know
so of what being together in a bigger
way yeah and she would like bring it up
some hey what I mean it was like maybe
three or four months you know but we'd
always been sweet on each other for a
long time like we'd been like sweet on
each other for like a decade cuz we did
a show for Comedy Central together a
long time ago other one Bert yeah hey
Bert Tiffany Haddish I remember I just
remember that show cuz I remember one
day Bert Kreischer showed up at the
improv or something he was like sweating
and he was all red and I was like yo
what's going on he's like I just drank
two bottles of soy sauce I was like what
show is that that's so Bert still sober
yeah
how many switz condiments but same bird
like know the show rap six months ago
just doing that thing kind of my thing
that's my stylist yeah just EpiPen
myself Fredman
okay so you've dated comics for real a
bunch really though she was really only
it yeah you know but yeah it just wasn't
I don't know she's a little more
emotionally efficient than I am
say that again a difference she's more
emotionally efficient what does that
mean like motions are inherently not
efficient right right
for me they're not you know for me it's
more of like a uh you mean she could
navigate them more easily than you know
she just like knows where she wants a
most you knows what she wants to but to
the point boy from my speed it wasn't it
wasn't a comfortable speed understanding
yeah I understand it's just I'm such a
robot I just want understanding yeah
that's like what a robot would say
understanding processing scary but like
that's the idea of dating a cut like so
you're not intimidated by a woman who
does comedy I think a lot of guys don't
love it no I'm not no I'm not I think
though I wonder like it when it gets to
like the sense of like having a family
and kids and like a month more of like
having a motherly environment be around
you like to be home when you're out why
don't want somebody with that [ __ ]
you know that Siberian woman but you
know what happened
I mean old no just means kind of
chorused yeah definitely brisk
I know like people hiking in the
distance make it you're so far away
there's sleigh dogs like I don't want
you know the epidemic of dating someone
who after you break up becomes a
comedian hmm or during their
relationship with you decides they want
to start comedy is a ramp yeah I dated
two guys like two years ago that Natalie
broke up all of a sudden they're like at
flappers oh yes correct
yes do you think you had that [ __ ] and
I know
the guy's name was Mike no but like also
what I know a lot of guys who are dating
her and I don't know if it's chicken or
egg I don't know if they they start
dating me because they want to be comics
and they want to learn how to do it or
if halfway through I somehow make it
look so [ __ ] easy that they're like I
can do that like I don't know but I know
a lot of guys who date girls and halfway
through they're like I think I want to
sort comedy do you think that they feel
like if they're not funny enough or
they're not in that world that you're
not gonna want to be with them
no I think they just general genuinely
see that like how you know they are she
just goes 20 minutes a night ya know
this it makes money like this is a
little hard she can do it I can [ __ ]
do it or it's my fault I blame myself
because I think I I learn early on you
have to laugh at a guy's jokes even if
you don't think they're funny cuz I'm
always trying to make sure you know what
I mean
like that I'm not somebody okay so yeah
so guys would be corny and I'm like
you're hilarious
I probably enabled it you thinks I'm
funny I'm yeah do that thing were you
juggling now I'm like getting the ball
getting bumped by my eggs [ __ ] ha
people just getting molested in the back
innocently a [ __ ] they got lotteries
yeah that's so person did you ever
dating me company said you didn't I
haven't dated any comics but you're
starting the book start again yeah I'd
like a manage I'm a developmental
executive at this point I'm just
talent I give my 10% for all these guys
but yeah who knows I don't know I think
this there is something extremely
attractive about somebody that can make
you laugh I think but it's also for me
like it's just like don't [ __ ] where you
eat and like it's already so hard to do
stand-up the only thing that would make
it worse if you had to like run into
your act oh yeah and the belly room like
working on new material or like having
your ex be like so booked in this girl
last night it's like wasn't that good
idea were you ever there when Gary
Gulman in April Macie got in a huge
fight at Westwood bruco when he was on
stage I think that's when I was like I'm
never dating comic [ __ ] ever I love
April I just I loved oh yeah I love I
think she's hilarious me too her story
about her mom and stuff is so he's he's
really funny too I just haven't seen a
lot of him letting everything go yeah
you've never seen Gary Gulman in
partying no I've never seen me watch
yeah this [ __ ] just 40 minutes
on sugar cookies like how is he coming
up with it like it's amazing he did like
an hour on orange juice like how have
you brush your teeth
mr. Gore's yeah like he's beautiful yeah
he's like Jimmy Schubert a little bit
it's like this weird art and he's like
six four and like it lying back her body
like and he does jokes about like
[ __ ] you know slim jim how is it so
he's like anyway so is it Westwood bruco
one night I can't believe you weren't
there this was $10 and all the shitty
nights I was there the one that's not
one where you miss and he was on stage
and like two people in the audience and
april/may he was like wait I don't know
how it happened but she was extreme it
was amazing but I was like I'm never
dating a comic that's what it's gonna
turn into can you imagine the only thing
worse than fighting with your boyfriend
or girlfriend is doing it in front of
college kids and other comics at 1:00
a.m. on a Tuesday and they don't know
either one is like well these fuck-ups
these people are [ __ ] in there for
tea
a nightmare we're going to hell I think
we're going that's what I'm most scared
I think April's dating someone they're
not together anymore no we're going to
hell everybody the whole group oh can
you imagine like if I was in a fight
with my ex and I was about to go on and
like work on new material and then he
[ __ ] shows up with his girlfriend
what great but here you get out of it
can you imagine that I would lose my
[ __ ] [ __ ] did you ever see when Mark
Marin and dumped David I've gotten a
fight in the o.r I didn't Wow
Wilde of was on stage or while Mark was
on stage and then they got in a big
fight yeah that's the kind of [ __ ] that
where you're just like you know what
this is worth it like one day I'll be
able to tell that story yeah I've had to
listen to mark know it's been hectic
sometimes yeah I want to yelled at that
were you there the night I yelled I feel
like we missed like four years I feel
like we missed every [ __ ] year I feel
like we have never we never really have
crossed that I yelled all the Comedy
Store comics and told them to class it
up it says a Connecticut thing this
somebody from Frank I lost my [ __ ] one
night because it does take a toll on you
like there were no female comics the
Tommies drop for so long and it was like
me and like 10 dudes you know and like I
was in bad relationship after bad
relationship and I think I had maybe so
my guy was with a cheetah not yeah I
think we had broken up and he'd just
like slept with someone like the next
day or something and I was angry anyway
and like yesterday I didn't have the
grit and I went in and I saw like
someone was there and talking about a
brought a girl that a different girl
from the night before like I don't think
I've done anything wrong but I just
snapped I can triggered me and like I
have all sorts it like at Westwood bruco
nobody comes in the parking lot you need
a class at all everyone needs a closing
up around like I snapped like boom I was
talking to my dad but I had to take it
out on you know the [ __ ] oor hallway
everybody I screamed at it's just dark
out there in the park
people got yeah basically I'm driving
Parker what did they say so how was the
fallout I think they learned pretty I
think they understood that it was like
my [ __ ] and then it was just it was
taking a toll on me to see these single
guys every night living the way they
live which is like no judgement I think
I was it was starting to like just wear
on me I think it was part of the reason
I also leave so fast cuz I'm like I
don't want to see your eyes I don't
wanna see any of that [ __ ] do you feel
like you want to see guys be better than
they are judgement like if you're not
raping anybody like if you're cheating
that's your business that's between you
and your wife that's not cheating is not
illegal right
like if you're my friend and I think you
love your wife and I know you're gonna
lose her like that's a bummer I maybe
I'll say something or if you have kids
but now like and if you're famous like
you know it's risky a lot of people's
jobs are at stake you know and and so
I'll feel bad but it's not my business
you know it's not my business but that
night I just lost it because I think
that the problem is being around guy but
also guys think of me as like a bro so
guys like yo just smash this chick last
night I'm just like don't tell me like
really [ __ ] up my paradigm of the
world right you know it's not healthy
for me to hear that all the time yeah
cuz I have to go out and date guys yeah
I don't wanna hear like the how the
sausage is spinning yeah yes ice cream
was like it was like dove and I met and
oh yeah Mike Young I remember it's a
lady's name bruh that is the Bermuda
Triangle a vagina will go missing on
between those three men that is a
Bermuda Triangle I don't even he's like
a nice guy anybody remember I think it
was there was somebody I think it was
like I'll magical came in and I was like
you're your guide like it was like yeah
you sell shoes yeah you're cool with me
the rest of you I literally was I don't
want to raise my arm suddenly show me
something I was doing a helicopter I was
like reading to class it up in the
parking lot like Petey Pablo it was a
bad batshit crazy I mean no no one has
spoken of it since and no one even has
the
like make fun of it or bring it up
because it's just 2 dollars
the Guana it's gonna be called the guano
episode it was batshit great that those
were the days of the store where it was
like [ __ ] was so nuts I was crazy I
remember I would go up like 1:00 in the
morning I learned a lot though there was
one time this actually changed my life I
had just I think it was around the same
time Mac shows going through some [ __ ]
and we're in the audience and my PO 1:00
in the morning there was this woman in
the audience like three like black women
in the back and I was talking about like
like I was having a real moment I would
just go on stage and like read text
messages to the audience fiction I
respond to this guy like I was just like
so anybody could be in there one in the
morning it wasn't about comedy I would
just literally go up like one person was
a hat maker that's who was on stage I'm
like what oh do you remember there was a
fight member that time burn and and
brenards got in a fight in the or the
Audis someone charged Dee burn while he
was onstage and they caught the guy and
this was back before food there was no
fool
there was no food there was no audience
it would used to walk on stage like
trevore and Cher yeah you'd come off
stage so dangerous emotionally
physically all of it there was no food I
don't think I was even drink brown paper
bags okay we're just saving spitting
there's like makers if you were making
water in the back pain there was like
there was no men in women's room it was
like [ __ ] boxes people holding each
other off of a back dock nightmare and
then one time I was on stage and a
bombing at 1:00 in the morning and I was
like you guys this guy he didn't call me
back what should I do and this woman
just went [ __ ]
she held at me they had no respect for
the Cobbers [ __ ] silence is the only
language men understand I was like yeah
like it was like a pep rally really it
was like an inspirational crazy crazy
it's all crazy
um do I'd love to talk to you again
sometime dark times starts I'm so crazy
I hope this wasn't too weird no this was
like one this is probably my second or
third favorite episode and we've only
had seven or eight guests Wow well this
the park has been gone for a year and
half but we just
having guess oh wow the pockets just
keeping growing and then why did you
decide to start having guests I don't
know what cuz I wanted to talk to
different people yeah you know and
because people want to see different
people's personalities interact that's
the biggest thing we got mellow though I
feel like we're mellow together not uh
that's it did you ever figure out that
joke about me easily you didn't have any
laughs we talked we telling the whole
time I laugh about anything and people
loved it did you um ever crack that joke
about the super from Spencer's gifts
what oh wait I forgot that what when my
dad bought me that Beetlejuice suit I
think my daddy to get me I didn't tell
Nick this my dad had to give me a suit
for a funeral and it was like around
Halloween or something any my mom was
out of town so he bought me a [ __ ]
like at a Rite Aid or something got me a
good Beetlejuice [ __ ] suit like
costume right yeah and we laughed about
that in the park and I was dying yeah
what's that spider in your pocket I
remember leaning down at the coffin oh
my god I'm so glad you're a great joke
right you just that was such a not a bet
I did it one time and people laugh
totally yeah one of the arms you raised
you know what play the theme from Addams
Family and didn't intend and I don't
think we can top that
Whitney Cummings will put all your stuff
at the top of the episode but no I think
your oh no the purple when you [ __ ]
it was a funeral
looks like the new that's a new business
suit the me to business Hollywood
because you're going
yeah that it has to be a funeral suit
from Spencer you turn on there's like a
skeleton on the man like we should just
write something that's base for like we
make a funny show thank you so much for
coming thank you be nice to me in the
comments I don't know what your fans are
like my fans are the nicest okay usually
yeah you never know
firing the kid rogue a oh oh Jesus
technically I guess I'm clinically obese
from the fighter I from the part of the
kid fan I learned that I'm over there
Ronda Rousey's gonna fight me like I
learned some [ __ ] about myself I'm shiny
my face is very shiny I learned um I
think you around me Jessica Biel a
little bit I don't think you'll really
yeah like Jessica Biel but also like one
of the hottest dudes ever that was in a
Shakespeare play a lot of guys women
yeah back then that's fair I'll take
that thank you no I appreciate come
names you know one you like have to pee
that the cast is over already give you
this you come on roads our sponsor this
is our sponsor rich and that's a really
dope charger Oh actually need this so
there you go yeah and so and they're
really clean but it's oh this is good
yeah they have nice stuff so do you need
this
good I'm gonna lose it if I take it out
of here okay
thank you so much Whitney
[Music]
like these leaves I must be but when I
reach that round I'll share this piece
of thought it's gonna take
a little town for me to set that parking
brake and let myself on my shine
[Music]